Hast du noch aktiv Kontakt mit irgendwelchen alten YouTubern von früher relativ selten?
Relativ selten?
Der Fabian, mit dem Fabian hatte ich auch schon Kontakt vorher.
Wir müssen das Ganze übrigens gleich noch auf Twitter posten.
Also, wir haben jetzt die Auswahl bei Musik heute, wie gesagt.
Wir können ein bisschen Kirby wieder dudeln lassen, bis wir durchdrehen im Kopf.
Oder wir machen ein bisschen Power-Metal an.
Was ich heute nicht anmache, wo ich heute keinen Bock drauf habe, ist irgendwelche Chill-Step-Geschichten.
So, Settings.
Ich wollte euch irgendwas zeigen.
Ich wollte euch gerade irgendwas zeigen.
Ich bin voll vergesslich gerade.
Ich habe doch gerade gesagt, ich wollte euch irgendwas zeigen.
Was wollte ich euch denn zeigen?
Ich habe es einfach wieder vergessen.
Ja, Raw-Input.
Stimmt denn?
Stimmt dann?
Ja, Borderless.
144Hz.
Das ist gut.
Field of View 85.
Ist auch gut.
Chromatic Apparation.
Alles aus.
Ich weiß zwar nicht, was es ist, aber erstmal aus.
Hauptsache, es ist das Wichtigste.
Erstmal aus.
Power-Metal.
Yeah.
So.
Leider.
Ich wollte ja die neue Map spielen.
Ich zeige euch das mal hier.
Leider gibt es die neue Map nicht.
Map.
Komm her.
Rotterdam.
No servers.
Gibt keinen.
Gibt keinen Rotterdam zum Spielen.
Woher hast du die Alpha?
Das ist doch gar nicht die Alpha.
Das ist die Open Beta.
Das Spiel hat aber mittlerweile mehr Bugs.
Also, ich habe gestern schon ein bisschen gespielt.
Ich bin jetzt, äh, ja, Medic Level 7.
Das ging relativ schnell.
Kann man sich eigentlich seine Stats irgendwo angucken?
Kann man sich, oh, das ist jetzt interessant.
Kann man sich seine Stats irgendwo angucken?
Stats?
Wo sind die Stats?
Man kann auf Rotterdam spielen, ist nur verbuggt.
Ja, aber wenn ich im Server-Browser nicht Rotterdam auswählen kann, wie kann ich dann auf Rotterdam spielen?
Verstehe ich nicht.
Äh, gestern kam auch, es kam nur, es kam nur Navi, Dings, Navic.
Es kam gestern nur.
Okay, Moment.
Wo, wo könnte ich meine Stats sehen?
Okay, Moment, Moment.
Ich muss auch kurz Curvy wegmachen.
So, also wir können, wir können, wir können Dings anmachen.
Wir können Hammerfall anmachen, wir können.
Oh, übrigens, mein neues Power-Metal-Technik.
Also, für, für die ganzen Metal-Leute hier.
Übelst geiles Album hier.
Ich meine, klingt schon Power-Metal-mäßig.
Also, viel mehr Power-Metal kann man nicht, äh, nicht klingen.
Ich meine, wenn man Rise of the Chaos Wizards heißt,
von einer Band, die sich Glory hammern hat, mehr Power-Metal geht eigentlich gar nicht.
Wenn man Rise of the Chaos Wizards heißt, von einer Band, die sich Glory hammern hat, mehr Power-Metal geht eigentlich gar nicht.
Oh, viel zu laut.
Aber übelst geil.
Ach, Conquest-Server wechseln immer nach jeder Runde.
Oh, Mann, das ist so ein verbuggter Sch...
Ich sag, ich sag doch, mehr Bugs,
mehr Bugs als die Alpha.
Äh,
habt ihr Quali-Settings?
Habt ihr keine Quali-Settings?
Warte mal, das muss ich mal kurz, muss ich mal kurz refreshen.
Warum habt ihr keine Quali...
Ihr solltet ja Quali-Settings haben.
Warum habt ihr keine Quali-Settings?
Ha...
Ja, ja, sorry,
kann ich nix machen.
Ich hab mal Quali-Settings, war hab ich keine Quali-Settings.
Wahrscheinlich streamen grad zu viele Leute.
Pech gehabt.
Nee, kann ich, kann ich nix machen.
Ich hab halt nur zur Auswahl, ich kann hier runterstellen,
also, ne, ich,
ich stream halt grad mit 7,5, 8 Mbit,
mittlerweile unterstützt das Twitch,
so, und nachdem ich nicht gepartnert bin und nix,
und auch immer noch nix gemacht hab in der Richtung,
ist halt die Sache, mal krieg ich Quality-Settings,
und mal krieg ich keine Quality-Settings, obwohl
es halt immer die gleichen
Settings sind.
Ein bisschen Hände aufwärmen, ey.
Kong-Fest.
Ey, wir spielen jetzt erst noch mal ein paar Runden zu,
zumindest war es zu warm, wir spielen jetzt noch mal ein paar Runden
Operation.
Immer noch grausame,
immer noch grausame
Map, also sowohl von den
Spawn-Punkten her, als auch mit,
übrigens der Sound ist an, ich hab bloß die Musik weg.
Das, das ist übelst geil.
Power-Metal-Beste.
Ja, meine Meinung zum Spiel bisher,
übrigens, wie ist Musik-Lautstärke zu mir?
Passt das so?
Also, ich werd die Musik beim Spiel ein bisschen leiser
machen, vor allem, wenn ich mich konzentrieren
muss. So, ähm,
ja, also
meine Meinung zum Spiel bisher, ich hab mir sogar
extra was aufgeschrieben.
Lautstärke perfekt, wunderbar.
Ähm, also ich hab mir extra was aufgeschrieben
zu dem Spiel, weil, falls ich ein Video
machen sollte, ja, ähm,
also, ähm,
aus geht los.
Ich find das
Spiel immer noch schlecht.
Ich, ich sag aber nicht einfach nur schlecht, ich kann es
auch noch begründen, weil, was euch wahrscheinlich mehr
interessiert, als dass ich es einfach schlecht finde. Ähm,
ich kann jetzt allerdings
aktuell nur für Operations sprechen
und auch nur für
Navig-Operations, weil
was anderes konnte ich noch nicht spielen.
So, das ist auch eine Sache, die mir
auf den Sack geht, diese Intros. Immer
die Intros, die ganze Zeit die Intros. Und du
kannst sie nicht wegklicken. Mir gehen die
Intros jetzt schon auf den Sack.
...
So, auf geht's.
So, zweiter Tag, das heißt wir haben wahrscheinlich erste Runde
übelst auf den Sack gekriegt.
Ähm, also die Map
ist grausig.
Sowohl von Spawns her als auch,
wir wollen Medics spielen.
Sowohl von den Spawns her
als auch von den Map
Begrenzungen.
Jetzt müsst ihr bloß noch dabei...
...Squad?
...Initial!
An phantom.
Wenigstens geht das Squadjoin mittlerweile schon.
Wir sind am zweiten.. Also was
auch nicht mehr geht, ist das hier, was
kacke finde. Das ging bisher in so
ziemlich jedem Battlefield, was man...
...иноaldo Bad Company 2 war eh geil, da bist du...
...piss dich Alte!
Oh, Moment.
Sensitivity stimmt nicht.
Die habe ich hier noch nicht eingestellt
But I got him or did I?
gardener
lerde
an dem ganzen Scheiß hängen, ne?
Also hier. Man bleibt hier immer noch
an irgendwie laufen. Seht ihr gleich, wenn ich hier
hochlaufe. Man bleibt hier immer noch an jedem
Scheiß hängen. Guck.
Alter, spring! Das ist so schlimm.
Das... Oh.
MonkaS.
Den retzen wir jetzt.
Wo müssen wir denn überhaupt hin? Ah, da. Okay.
Ja, also was sag ich zum Game?
Das ist, ähm...
Also auf dieser Map zumindest. Es gibt keine
klaren Fronten. Das ist ganz merkwürdig. Die Map-Begrenzungen
sind komisch. Die Spawn-Points sind komisch.
Die, ähm...
Die Progression auf der Map ist komisch.
Das ist irgendwie so ein Hybrid aus Conquest und Rush
und davon irgendwie nix, nix
gescheit. Man kennt nicht richtig, wo
die Auszonen sind. Und das
Hüppen funktioniert halt immer noch nicht.
Und das geht mir halt richtig auf den Sack. Ich versuche hier mal
Yolorets zu machen.
Äh, okay.
Und da gibt es immer...
Da gibt es immer so kleine Bugs, wie ihr gerade gesehen
habt.
Zwischendurch. Dass man dann hängen bleibt oder irgendwie die
Aktion nicht ausgeführt wird oder so. Und dann verreckt man
dadurch immer halb. Das ist so...
sehr, sehr...
merkwürdig. Man hat auch viel zu wenig
Munition. Guck mal. Ich hab jetzt... Ich hab nix gemacht
im Endeffekt. Die Munition ist schon leer.
Es stehen auch nicht...
Es stehen auch keine Munitionskisten
in Reichweite, dass man sagen könnte...
Ich glaub, das ist...
Ich weiß nicht so genau, wo er ist.
Piss dich mal.
Ah. Was ist der?
Unser Gegner?
Irgendwo hier ist einer.
Perfekt.
Heben wir das Ding mal auf.
Ist das eine Shotgun? Nee, das ist ein Thompson oder sowas, ne?
Sektor.
Übrigens, wisst ihr, was das Schlimme ist?
Woran man sieht, dass ich relativ viel Overwatch
gespielt hab in meinem Leben?
Es hängt. Es hängt einfach.
Es hat einfach jetzt hängen geblieben.
Ähm...
Ja, ich weiß hier... Nee, das ist keine Muni.
Die Munikiste ist das.
Woran man sieht, dass ich relativ viel...
Overwatch geschrieben hab, ist dieser Tick.
Seht ihr das?
Dieser Tick.
Jetzt haben alle Overwatch-Spieler diesen Tick.
Was bin ich eigentlich jetzt?
Ich bin Support, ne?
Ja.
Nee.
Medic?
Ich glaub, ich bin Support.
Übrigens, ich muss Dings umstellen.
Schuss.
Viel besser mit diesen Dingern immer Single-Schuss zu machen.
Weil die meisten Waffen so krass verziehen,
dass du keine Chance hast über Range.
Mit der hier hab ich jetzt noch nicht gespielt.
Ja, ein CS. Ja, ein CS macht man es auch.
Aber...
Aber Overwatch ist ganz extrem.
Hallo? Leg dich hin.
Ah! Ich hab falsch gemappt.
Oh. Sekunde. Leute, warte mal.
Ich muss... Ah ja. Leg dich hin.
Ich muss ummappen.
Fuck. Ähm...
Keybindings.
On foot.
Prone. Nee. Nee.
Crouch. Crouch. Crouch. Prone. Prone.
Prone will ich.
Ich hab mich verdrückt hier.
Prone.
Ja, ja. Was? Nein.
Äh...
Clear.
Clear. Perfekt.
Ich hab immer...
Ja. Hinschmeißen bei Battlefield auf rechter Maustaste.
Moin, Apollo X-Plane.
Du bist Cyrus-Sub, oder?
Sind Sie nicht Cyrus?
Emotes?
Waffe.
Legehände machen wir jetzt.
Guck mal, wie das... Habt ihr gesehen, wie das hin und her wackelt?
Das ist auch wieder sowas, wo du dich teilweise denkst,
da fuck...
Wie soll's denn so...
Wie willst du denn sowieso schießen, teilweise?
Ja, so rumwackelt.
Hier ist einer.
Übrigens, das ist das Beste, was man machen kann in diesem Battlefield.
Alle Autowaffen erstmal auf Single-Schuss stellen.
Und dann halt ein bisschen zielen.
Hä.
Übrigens, gestern, ne? Ich hab's ja auf Twitter gepostet.
Jede Runde, oder fast jede Runde, irgendwie 55, 56, sonst was, Kills.
Über uns.
Rekt.
Ich steh hier relativ unglücklich.
Ja, ich steh hier echt relativ unsinnig.
Ah ja, und das Spotten ist auch ganz merkwürdig.
Ich sag euch gleich, nach der Runde sag ich euch...
Ich hab mir nämlich ein bisschen was aufgeschrieben zu dem Game.
Wie gesagt, falls ich dazu ein Video mach.
Suppression.
Es ist einfach mal in die Richtung...
Oh, von da oben kommt was.
Rekt.
Oh ne, ich bin ja kein Medic.
Oh, doch, ich bin...
Oh, ich bin kein Medic.
Bin ich doch Medic?
Was bin ich überhaupt?
Ich weiß nicht mal, was ich bin.
Oh, Megalol.
Schnippsort.
Übrigens, Achterping.
Nahezu unspielbar.
Moment, ich hab zu wenig FPS.
Ich hab zu wenig FPS, das stimmt fast nicht.
Ähm...
Das...
Ach ja, deswegen hab ich zu wenig.
Es gibt das neue Setting.
Minimal Latency, beste.
Hat man auch ordentlich FPS dann.
Und das Spiel hat übrigens zwei Spawn-Bugs aktuell.
Und die sind so schlimm, dass man dadurch quasi die komplette Runde nicht mehr spawnen kann.
Man bleibt drin, aber man kann die komplette Runde nicht mehr spawnen.
Was ziemlicher Sack ist.
So.
Wir flanken jetzt mal hier außen rum.
Moment.
Ich muss mal kurz überlegen.
Ach, wir sind noch gar nicht am letzten.
Wir sind ja noch gar nicht am letzten.
Oh, der hat voll den Kopf gekriegt.
Die SMGs sind übrigens nicht so gut.
Die sind übrigens auch auf Range richtig schwach.
Ich weiß nicht, ob die in der Alpha auch schon so schwach waren.
Aber diesmal sind die SMGs übelst räudig auf Range.
Ich hab dem grad dreimal in den Kopf geschossen.
Und so hat er 53 Damage gekriegt.
Und was immer noch so ist, man kriegt random Headshots.
So, so.
Du läufst jetzt hier hoch.
Aber bumm.
Einfach irgendwie von der Seite weggeschneibert.
So, jetzt haben wir's.
Ach, haben sie das jetzt gefixt, Ducky?
Okay.
Also gestern hatte ich das noch.
Und ich konnte auch...
Ich konnte auch gar nicht mehr so richtig ins Minimum.
Üh.
Flanke Reno.
Give ammo.
Ammo.
Piss dich.
Self-Heal.
Das ist auf 5.
Ich hab noch nicht gefunden...
Also, man kann sich auf 5 Self-Healen.
Die Sache ist, ich hab noch nicht gefunden, wie man diesen Knopf umlegen kann.
Weil ich würd den Knopf gerne umlegen auf zweite Maustaste.
Hängen bleiben.
Au.
Sind Panzer irgendwo am Start?
Wow.
Nix, wie weg.
1080p.
1080.
Ich hab nur 1080.
Nur, in Anführungsstrichen, 1080.
Next, please.
Das müsste ne, ne Brandgranate sein.
Nix da.
Oh, da ist was drinne.
Der will gebasht werden.
Oder auch nicht.
Oh.
Kommt was?
Das, dieses, dieses...
Guck, so dieses, dieses krassen Ding.
Also, das ist von der Seite immer gebasht.
Ich hab leider die, die Aufnahmen nicht auf ner Platte, wo ich drauf zugreifen kann.
So, ich hatt gestern den ultra geilen Clip.
Am Anfang hier vorne links, hab ich irgendwie gefühlt 8 Leute weggesprayt.
Das war sehr, sehr nice.
Respawn, respawn, respawn, respawn.
Nope.
Oh, da fährt ein Auto rum.
Vielleicht darf ich ja respawnen.
Nice.
Aber man muss sagen, das Spiel ist deutlich besser, viel, viel besser als Battlefield 1.
Battlefield 1 ging mir ja schon...
Ich weiß nicht, ob es die Alpha oder die Beta war, so sehr oft und sagt, dass ich mir gedacht hab, ich kauf mir das Game gar nicht.
Ähm, in der Form würde ich mir aktuell das Game auch nicht kaufen.
Es sei denn, es läuft, es hat weniger Bugs.
Weil ich mein, es kann ja nicht sein, dass du quasi schon das fünfte Spiel auf Frostbite Basis im Endeffekt machen und es immer noch so verbuggt ist.
Ich mein, klar, da sind immer neue Games, aber die Grundlage ist doch die gleiche.
Höp, höp.
Ach, das ist eine von mir.
Und Front, Front verlaufen ist übrigens immer noch nicht klar.
Auch sehr merkwürdig in dem Game.
Du weißt nur, dass die Gegner irgendwo von da kommen, oder auch nicht.
Irgendwo von hier.
Und jetzt krieg ich Damage, und weiß nicht warum.
Aber Flankerino machen wir jetzt mal.
Höp, höp.
Ich dachte, die kommt vielleicht hierher, aber hier kommt nix.
Mittendrin.
also
das ist das ist übrigens auch übelst nervig
dieses rum gehüpft also dieses rumgerolle der gegner auf dem boden wenn sie schon eigentlich down sind
Richtig nervig da weißt du manchmal nicht was dauerndes und was nicht dauerndes
Vor welcher seite
Was max was sagst du dazu dass rapper buschini und kollege anfangen auf twitch zu streamen glaubst dass er zukommt die typen die sind so
Populär so bekannt die können auf jeder plattform streamen und die konnten sie könnten sogar auf auf
Mixer streamen und das würden leute gucken
Also ich bin ehrlich ich brauche jetzt buschino und kollega nicht unbedingt auf pitch
haft befehl wäre geil aber
aber also ich brauche keine waffe was machen die dann also
letztendlich twitch ist ja im kerne
Alter wo ist denn hier immer was im kern eine
gaming-plattform das darf man nicht vergessen
Was ey dieses game du weißt die wo was ist
Ich habe keine ahnung wo geht da sind
Gehen wir mal hier ins haus
war wo streamt da
weiß
Ich kann jetzt da nicht raus ich hab schiss
Ich war hatte das gesehen wieder darum geklatscht ist gerade der soldat ich bin aus dem fenster gesprungen erst ich konnte erst mal eine halbe
minute nicht eben nichts machen weil er hin und her gesprungen ist
also ich habe keine
mit der maus gemacht gerade außer beim letzten mal auf den gegner
Das ging wirklich so
das hast du in dem game laufen du fühlst du hast man im game oft das gefühl du hast jetzt wenn du quasi
eine aktion macht keine kontrolle mehr was zu machen wissen dann springt ja und dann macht dann erst mal gefühl fünf sekunden
Und dann kann man wieder was machen
Im battle 4 in bed company 2 welch aus dem fenster gesprungen werden beide tot
hast du deine meile zu rainbow six game?
Na ja klar schon lange
dachte ja noch während der alpha das oder
damals als neu war dachte ich das wird der übelste reinfall
Aber ist es nicht geworden ziemlich gut mittlerweile
komm an
seite rechts
wo ist er
leg dich hin
hab doch da rechts irgendwo einen gesehen jetzt
ist fertig
wir sind spät gejoint
ja dudeldöner so ist es das ist das kommt die animation sind übelst zäh
und was wir halt nicht auf diese diese zwischen intros
Er hat da gesehen ist voll übertrieben mit der animation
die was was sie geändert haben oder was wir zumindest so vorkommt ist dass die
wiederbelebt animationen sind kürzer als in der alpha
kannst du namen der band in den in den chat schreiben das ist glory hammer
oh ja das darf natürlich auch nicht fehlen
glory hammer also glory und hammer
was ist
rise of the chaos wizard besser besserer namen kann im power metal album einfach nicht haben habe ich ein upgrade für medic gekriegt
Nope
das ist auch eine sache die habe ich nicht verstanden
Gibt es dann später
gibt es dann spät vielleicht weiß dass jemand gibt es dann später noch mehr medic rollen die man auswählen kann
weil ich mal aktuell jetzt bin ich ja medic
level 7 und ich kann nur viel medic machen aber ich meine wenn es doch für die medic klasse quasi ein extra combat rolls menü gibt
da muss es doch dann auch später mehr geben
Ja fallschirmanimation bed company 2 heruntergesprungen fallschirm gut war
Und das nächste ist was mit diesem gadget hier um kann ich das eigentlich
sowieso ganz finde ich so ganz verstehe ich das menü
also es ist ein bisschen umständlich ja aber es funktioniert schon deutlich besser als in der alpha
está
Weil ich sage wo ist es anstrengender zu streamen und ordentlich zu spielen als nur ordentlich zu spielen
wir schauen ganz schönen unterschied
Ja und viel zu wenig aber kannst du dir recht geben
Ja diroальer ist übrigens auch ein schadens missions eliass civilian
ja und abortion ist noch so was
so. Es ist normal in dem Game, dass man nichts versteht.
Also die Frontlinien sind quasi, zumindest hier auf
Navig-Operations
sind quasi nicht vorhanden. Du weißt überhaupt nicht, wo was
passiert.
Übrigens, was auch komisch ist, dass man
nicht anlocken kann
während des Games.
Also das hier,
ich kann jetzt beispielsweise nicht während
die Map wechselt oder so,
kann ich jetzt nicht mal kurz mein Medic customizen.
Ich muss dann immer komplett raus.
Was natürlich blöd ist. Jetzt überlegt man sich
mal, man spielt... Wie sieht man
eigentlich seine Stats? Wie sieht man seine Stats?
Jetzt überlegt euch mal, ihr spielt
im...
Was ist denn das?
Ja. Überlegt euch mal,
ihr spielt im Squad.
Okay, machen wir jetzt das einfach mal.
Ja, stellt euch mal vor, ihr spielt im Squad
und laufen müsst ihr vom Server runter,
weil irgendwie einer sein Zeug customizen will.
So nervig.
Das ist...
Wo sieht man seine Stats?
Man muss doch irgendwie einen Trans-Vergleich machen.
Wo sieht man denn seine Stats?
Also ich würde sagen, von der Idee her bei Your Company,
aber...
Wer ist denn da noch online?
Aber bei
Your Company... Ich meine, es wäre schön,
wenn man sich die Stats angucken könnte, zum Beispiel
pro Klasse oder so, aber das
finde ich hier nicht.
Als nächstes würde ich sagen,
Armory, das ist aber auch keine Stats.
Wo kann ich mir Stats
angucken?
Assignments, aber Assignments ergibt
eigentlich überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Ähm...
Machen wir mal ein Firefox auf.
Äh...
Solange das Game sucht.
Battlefield 5 Stats.
Gibt es da irgendwie was?
Battlefield 5 Stats?
Dazu gibt es doch eine Webseite.
Das ist bestimmt Skamats, das ist bestimmt Fake.
Achso, ja,
irgendwas zum Selbstinstallieren, dass ich
einen schönen Virus am Start habe, ganz bestimmt.
Also ich bin...
Also ich...
Ich...
Ich weiß nicht, wie man Ingame-Stats angucken kann.
Wir sind...
Sind wir Defense? Wir sind Defense.
Hallo?
Also, man sieht jetzt...
Man weiß nicht, warum der Bildschirm schwarz wird.
Ah, weil das Intro kommen muss.
We have taken Navik.
Habt ihr auch Navik getaked?
This is a nice fake German accent.
Jetzt hängt's gelb.
Yeah!
Bestes Opening auf der Map.
Zeige ich euch jetzt mal.
Er klappt nicht immer.
Immer noch Intro, übrigens.
Man denkt, man kann jetzt demnächst mal anfangen zu spielen,
aber so einfach ist es ja nicht.
Ja.
Übrigens ist es auch nicht logisch, wo man spawnt.
Manchmal spawnt man hier vorne bei dem Zug
und manchmal spawnt man...
Man weiß es nicht so genau.
Ja, bestes Opening.
Man bräuchte ein paar Leute, die hier vorne
Dinge aufbauen.
Das habe ich noch nicht gecheckt, wie das geht
Man kann hier vorne Barrikaden errichten
Ich weiß aber nicht, wie es geht
Und ohne Barrikaden ist hier vorne ziemlich kacke
Aber
Hier ist in der Regel bestes Opening für die Map
Und man kann, wenn die hier drinnen sind
Kann man hier oben drauf klicken
Auch wenn die Animationen manchmal ein bisschen rumspacken
Also man kann eigentlich
Wenn die Animationen geht, kann man hier oben drauf
Glaubt es mir, dass es geht
Ah, jetzt geht es
Und dann kann man da runter bashen
Ah, guck, da baut er
Der ist ein guter Mann
Der weiß Bescheid
Wie baut man?
Man hat irgendwie einen Hammer
Hallo, ich wollte dich gerade retzen, Kollege, aber
Kein Bock
Oh, da ist einfach so ein Ding vorm Kopf
Oh, oh, legt sich hin, Alter
Der kommt jetzt gleich hoch
Der wird gebasht
Okay, oder auch nicht
Den müssen wir retzen, den müssen wir unbedingt retzen
Hallo, ich will retzen
Ich helfe dir
Guck, habt ihr wieder gesehen, die Ratsanimationen haben funktioniert
Das ist ein ganz schöner
Fail-Bob
Kommt her
Und dieses Eingepläne, ey
Kann man das ausschalten?
Guck, ich habe schon wieder keine Munition mehr
Why?
Oh, nicht alle
Und es waren drei Headshots oder so
Juckt uns nicht
Who cares?
Haha, Headshot, null
Jetzt gehen wir, jetzt machen wir Trick 17, Achtung
Komm her
Oh, von der Seite kommt was
Ich sage euch, beste Opening-Position, glaubt's mir
Und Pistolen-Munition hat man genug
Ich bräuchte halt ein bisschen Munition, ne?
Das wäre schon nicht schlecht
Munition ist halt komplett overrated
Ja, warum man bei mir nur in 1080p schauen kann, liegt daran, dass Twitch mir mal wieder keine Qualitätsoptionen zugestanden hat
Yeah, ich habe Munition
Nein, habe ich nicht
Aber jetzt habe ich Munition
Und es ist Immersive, ja, Immersive as fuck
Ey, meine Maus ist weg
Meine Maus ist weg
Habt ihr es gerade gesehen?
Der Fokus von meiner Maus war weg
Ich konnte nicht umdrehen
Das Game ist mega verbuggt
So muss das sein
Da war Maus-Fokus weg gewesen gerade
Einfach so, so, wupp
Darfst nicht mehr steuern
Hast so viele Kills gemacht
Darfst jetzt nicht mehr steuern
Overrated, jebaited ist das
Aber hier unten an den
An den Zügen ist wirklich die, die beste
Die beste Opening-Position überhaupt
Ich glaube, da hinten steht einer
Kann das sein?
Nee, hab ich da einen gesehen?
What the fuck?
What? Wo?
In dem Game, das hat keine Frontlinien
Ah, Seite
Man hat zu wenig Munition
Ich meine, du, wenn du eine gute Position hast, dann ist das eine gute Position
Wenn du eine gute Position hast, ist es halt übelst räulich, wenn du permanent
Da quasi weg musst und an irgendeine Kiste rennen
Dann guck mal, du spawnst mit gerade mal 60 Munition
Bei einer SMG wohlgemerkt
Bei einer SMG 60 Schuss, das ist ja nix
90, okay
Drei Magazinen, okay
Aber 60?
Plus ein Magazin schon dabei?
Das ist nix
Und das war dann eben scheiße
Das hängenbleibt, so wie hier jetzt
Warum? Warum bleib ich hier hängen?
Du bist doch krasser Soldat, warum kannst du hier nicht hoch?
Und dieses Geblitze von irgendwelchen Achievements und so ist auch übelst akkord
Geh wieder vor
Weiß
Die holen wir uns
Next
Next, please
Weiter geht's
So muss das sein
Pogas! Hallo, ich will retzen
Ich will retzen, ich darf nicht
Ah, jetzt hab ich's
Hätte klappen können
Ähm, übrigens, Rettanimation finde ich immer noch
Rettanimation finde ich übrigens immer noch einen Ticken zu lang
Weil
Letztendlich das Schöne
Das Schöne an Medics ist
Dass in der Regel
Also wenn gute Leute Medics spielen
Dann ist das gut für sie und das Team
Weil die quasi nebenbei noch das Team supporten können
Es werden quasi, wenn gute Leute Solo spielen
Werden sie immer die Klasse nehmen, wo sie sich nicht so gut fühlen können
Wo du am wenigsten auf das Team angewiesen bist
Das ist einfach so
Weil verlässt du dich public komplett auf das Team
Bist du quasi verloren
Was nicht heißen soll, dass ich mir das übertrieben gut in dem Game einschätzen würde
Aber Leute, die wirklich gut sind
Du spielst automatisch Klassen
Also die Owner
Sagen wir's mal so
Die Owner spielen automatisch Klassen, wo sie
Wo sie alleine gut klarkommen
Und wenn man quasi jetzt
Jemand der Owns
Quasi dazu zwingt
Lange Rettanimation zu machen
Wird das dazu führen, dass sie Medic spielen
Allerdings nicht retten
Weil es ja für sie selbst extrem gefährlich ist
Was Blödsinn ist
Du musst quasi jemand
Der gut ist
Und quasi das Team carryt
Plus Wiederbeleben
Kann auch noch dazu unterstützen
Indem du ihm ermöglichst
Quasi Team Support zu machen
Während er Owned
Was halt mit langen Wiederbeleben Animationen nicht geht
Versteht man was ich meine
Weil in der Regel hast du quasi dadurch
Dass Medic in der Regel die Klasse ist
Die alleine am besten zurecht kommt
Hast du schon mal einen super hohen Support Anteil
Also quasi Heal und Rett
Für das Team
Du musst den Leuten aber halt auch ermöglichen
Das zu machen
Ohne dass sie sich zu sehr in ihrem Spiel einschränken müssen
Sonst hast du
Sonst hast du 30 Medics im Team
Und davon retten 25 net
Guck mal wie wir Owned übrigens gerade
Du bist weg
Piss dich
Ich bräuchte Munition
Und diese Rage Doll
Rackdoll Dinger sind auch
Und die Rackdoll Dinger sind auch
Okay das war jetzt zu viel
Das war zu viel
Das können wir mal aufnehmen
Weil das war eine ganz coole Runde bis jetzt
Ey geh weg
The enemy has planes
Der gezwungene deutsche Akzent
Ist voll der Wahnsinn
Es ruckelt
Es darf nicht ruckeln
Ich hab den schnellsten Rechner
Den man kaufen kann zur Zeit
Das Game darf nicht ruckeln
In low settings
Ich muss mal kurz hier weg
War das der gleiche Typ der mich gekriegt hat?
Ah ne von der Seite
Das sind low se- äh ja
Übrigens wir haben sie übelst gereckt
Guck dir das mal an
Nice
Das sind low set
Oder hat sich das wieder gesettet
Ich hab es vorhin auf low settings umgestellt
Übrigens dass man auch in diesen komischen Intro Outros
Keine settings umgestellt hat
Keine settings umstellen darf es auch nervig
1080k
8700k plus
1080ti
Ist einfach deutlich zu langsam für das Spiel
Ist halt so
Man muss halt auch mal der Wahrheit ins Gesicht sehen
Jetzt dürfen wir uns wieder ein schönes Intro angucken
Das war doch eine ganz schöne Runde
cks
hut
Stemmen
Als
today
C
Sowohl als Attack als auch auf Defense.
So, hier kann es sein, dass man auf den Sack kriegt oder zwei Leute out.
Kommt drauf an.
Das ist immer ein gutes Opening.
Ich habe die Map schon ein bisschen studiert.
Okay, das war jetzt natürlich für den Arsch.
Das passiert ja halt. Das ist halt von allen Seiten.
Aber Opening auf der Map ist am besten, wenn du es immer an die linke Seite machst.
Ich habe das Game direkt outgefigert.
So ist es.
Okay, gibt keinen Ratz. Kann er auch gar nicht.
Da steht er irgendwo rum.
Sonstwo.
Jetzt mal hier spawnen.
Und das ist auch ein Punkt, den ich nicht verstehe.
Man klickt auf der Map auf den Spawnpunkt und man spawnt ganz woanders.
Habt ihr es gesehen? Ich habe auf diesen Spawnpunkt da geklickt.
Da würde man davon ausgehen, man spawnt hier auch irgendwo.
Aber nein, man spawnt da.
Das ist ein Drittel der Map weiter weg vom Spawnpunkt.
Wo man sich denkt, warum ist dann der Spawnpunkt da auf der Map, wo man spawnen kann?
Wenn man, wenn man doch dort, dort, da nicht spawnt, ne?
Weiß man nicht genau.
Rekt!
Ich wollte ihn eigentlich gerade messern.
Ich höre sie links neben, äh, rechts neben mir laufen.
Ich habe Schiss.
Ich habe Schiss. Ich verrecke jetzt, wenn sie die Flankerino-Action macht.
Okay, ich hau ab.
Ich hau ab.
Weg hier.
Gibt es Countermessern? Ich glaube nicht.
So.
So, jetzt zeig, jetzt, jetzt kann man nämlich hier hoch.
Wenn diese scheiß Animation funktioniert, kann man hier hoch und nicht von oben bashen.
Das Problem ist, seht ihr diese Animation? Das ist so fail, dass Animationen nicht funktionieren.
Du musst fünfmal, du musst fünfmal klicken, dass diese scheiß Animation kommt.
Und ich hab's euch, ich hab's mit Ankündigung, mit Ankündigung, das war mit Ankündigung.
Ich hab gesagt, ich geh jetzt da hoch und dann werden sie gebasht.
Ne, aber ich bin nicht hochgekommen.
Das ist...
Kacke. Sackgröße.
Ansonsten kann man auch schon ganz gut bashen in dem Game.
Das ist schon, schon recht nice, ja.
Also wenn die, wenn das noch alles ein bisschen, sagen wir mal, präziser wird, ja.
Also sprich, dass du, dass du auch das Gefühl hast, du hast die Kontrolle, was passiert in dem Game.
Dann wird das, das, das bashfest.
Wow.
Ach, 25, kannste nix sagen.
Achso, spotten ist übrigens random, ich weiß.
Da hab ich bis jetzt noch nicht gecheckt, wie man spottet richtig.
Au.
Ein Gegner.
Ja.
Nicht gesehen.
Also was ich zum Spotten schon probiert hab...
Oh, Rats.
Danke.
Nice, nice.
Was ich zum Spotten schon probiert hab, ist gucken, Q drücken, Q drücken und gucken.
So, und manchmal spottet er dann, ich weiß nicht genau wann.
Das ist doof.
Das ist wirklich doof.
Und das, das, das, das wie die Sonne blendet.
Und das auch.
Krass.
Ich bin hier ein bisschen exposed.
Die gucken da zu mir und kriegen es halt gebacken.
Okay, ich umlaufe die jetzt mal ein bisschen.
Was ist das hier?
Ah.
Ein Gewehr, ein Gewehr ohne Munition.
Okay, dann nehm ich die bei Mainz wieder.
Ah, Moni all.
Ah, Pistole.
Wie, das ist eine Sache, die mir in dem Game wirklich gut gefällt.
Man muss ja mal was positives sagen.
Die Pistolen sind nice.
Also die Pistolen gefallen mir gut.
Also auf, natürlich nur auf nah.
Ah, da ist, da ist, da ist.
Moni.
Gift.
Nice.
Ganze 12 Schuss.
Wieder keine Schuss.
Okay, wow.
Ich muss hier weg.
Sind mir zu ge...
Alter.
Haut ab.
Okay, wo sind Gegner?
Haben wir Gegner?
Ach, da hinten.
Fuck.
Hier, hier steht eine Monikiste.
Also meistens steht hier eine Monikiste.
Jetzt steht gerade keine Monikiste da.
Also...
Ach, die ist kaputt.
Okay.
Die Monikiste ist kaputt.
Das ist unglücklich.
Rätsel.
YOLO Rätsel.
Ich kann nicht rätseln.
Geht nicht.
Animation ging nicht.
Ah.
The Pantsman ist am Start.
Ich höre den Pa...
Das ist ein Panzer.
Okay.
Ja, eh gut.
335.
Man kann ja auch irgendwann mal sterben, ne?
Es wäre cool, wenn es so eine...
So eine Kombination gäbe.
Quasi...
Das war...
Das war so eine...
Man hatte ja in...
In Battlefield 3 war das, glaube ich.
Da hattest du ja so einen Perk für mehr Munition.
Das wäre hier wirklich praktisch.
Wo du es dann auch als Teamperk nehmen konntest.
Das war schon nice.
Irgendwo rechts war hier doch was.
Wo ist er?
Okay.
Off-Range ist halt die Sub-Machine ganz übelst räudig.
Deswegen meine ich, sie sind da auch viel zu wenig Schuss.
Da unten war doch noch einer, oder?
Ach ne.
Das ist die...
Dann zappeln die Gegner auch so.
Du denkst, warum zappeln die so?
Muss weg.
YOLO.
Oh.
Auf.
Komm her.
Bashen.
Pistolen-Bash.
Du willst hier laufen und dann Pistolen-Bashen, weil du keine Munition mehr hast?
Give...
Give ammo.
Please.
Kann man sich aus denen noch was rausnehmen?
Geht das hier auch?
Nein.
Pech gehabt.
Oh.
Die Musik ist fertig.
Wir müssen...
Next.
Oh.
Ich lebe wieder.
Pech.
Aber 7 und 36.
Läuft.
Ist doch nice.
Übrigens, falls ich was überlese.
Ich konzentriere mich gerade relativ stark aufs Game.
Schreibt das ganze Loch hier mit addwubblers in Chat dann, dass ich sehe.
Sparren.
Kollege.
Fork dich.
Auf.
Oh.
Hallo.
Spawnen.
No longer available.
Aber ich sehe ihn doch.
Fake News.
Ich habe einfach mal 416 Punkte gekriegt für...
Für...
Ich weiß nicht so genau.
Und ich habe die Killstreak-Taste schon wieder vergessen.
Was war nochmal die Killstreak-Taste?
YOLO Rats.
Leute, wisst ihr nochmal was die Killstreak-Taste war?
Kann mir das gerade nochmal einer sagen?
Was war die Killstreak-Taste?
Es gibt ja Killstreaks in dem Game.
Es gibt was.
Ja.
Über Range zacken.
Die heißt...
Oh.
Okay.
Motherfucker.
Es ist ja vollkommen legitim, dass...
No-no-no-no.
PenSpan.
Aber es ist vollkommen legitim, dass es zackt übrigens.
Über Range.
Jetzt habe ich...
Alter.
Panzer, kannst du mal abhauen?
Ich habe Schiss.
Der Panzer.
Ich habe Angst, dass der mich debatet.
Und jetzt ausgestiegen ist, oder so.
Fuck.
Ich weiß nicht, wo wir hoch ist.
Okay.
Hier ist nichts.
Ist schlecht.
Okay, ich muss hier weg.
Der Panzer ist immer noch vor mir.
Ja, ja, ist gut.
Hau ab.
Weg.
Wir gehen jetzt mal hier rüber.
Oh, oh, die pushen hier ganz schön hart rein.
Vielleicht kommen wir hier durch.
Wenn wir Glück haben, können wir unten noch ein bisschen aufräumen.
Puh.
Okay, das war ein bisschen doof von mir.
Aber ein bisschen viele.
Ja, die Runde ging gut los,
aber jetzt gerade ein bisschen kacke.
Okay, next.
Eigentlich wollte ich da spawnen.
Ja, spawnen wir halt da.
Guck mal, da bin ich gespawnt
und ich spawn wieder in einem Drittel-Map hintendran.
Das ist total im Vier.
Wenn sie mir schon anzeigen, dass ich an B spawne,
dann sollte ich halt auch an B spawnen.
Aber nee, stimmt gar nicht.
Ich habe mich verguckt.
Vergesst, was ich gesagt habe.
Ich bin ja gar nicht B gespawnt.
Wir sind Gegner 100 pro.
Müssen.
Aber ich glaube,
hier funktioniert es.
Vorne ist das Map aus.
Da hinten waren welche.
Wow.
Alter, heil dich.
Ich habe 5 gedrückt.
Okay, das ist kacke.
Da stehen so viele Gegner da.
Äh.
Ja, stimmt.
Genau, was war der Knopf nochmal für die Killstreaks?
Ich weiß den Knopf dafür nicht mehr.
Die werden jetzt gebasht.
Bäsche re-node werden die jetzt.
Gehen wir da rum.
Wow.
Von wo?
Weiß es nicht.
Ich will den spotten.
Ich darf den nicht spotten.
Okay, random Headshot von sonst wo.
Es ist so fail.
Warum kann ich die Gegner nicht spotten vor mir?
Was soll das?
Weiß ich nicht.
Ich hab den angeguckt.
Ich hab da Q gedrückt.
Warum?
Was soll der kacke?
Ich meine, es ist ja nicht schon genug Anreiz, irgendwie Recon Camp kacke zu spielen, was
in jedem Battlefield geht.
Ich habe da einen Kacke.
Ich habe einen Kacke.
Was soll der Kacke?
Ich meine, es ist ja nicht schon genug Anreiz, irgendwie Recon Camp kacke zu spielen, was
in jedem Battlefield die Pest ist.
Ich kann doch nicht nur einen Recon spotten lassen.
Das geht doch nicht.
Ich seh es nicht.
Welche Seite kommen sie?
Kommen sie oben?
Kommen sie unten?
Die zweite Phase von der Map habe ich noch nicht so richtig gecheckt.
Ja, darf ich jetzt oben drauf?
Ich fahre übrigens schon lange auf dem Rückweg, ja.
Aber die Animation hat halt wieder zu lange gedauert.
Ich hasse dieses...
Mir geht das wirklich...
Also wenn ich eine Sache an dem Spiel sagen müsste,
was mich wirklich nervt und was auch der Hauptgrund ist,
das, was mich vom Kauf abhält,
dann ist es diese Animation.
Du hast für jeden Scheiß irgendeine Animation,
in der du nichts machen kannst.
Ich meine, die sollen mich einfach spielen lassen.
Es ist doch egal, ob ich jetzt schön von der Kiste runtersteige oder nicht.
Hauptsache, ich komme von der Kiste schnell runter,
wenn ich von der Kiste runter will.
Hier sieht irgendwo Map aus, oder?
War hier nicht Map aus?
Hier ist Map aus.
Hau!
Oh, Gott.
Es geht aber nichts gerade.
So, zack.
Wir müssen mal irgendwie eine gute Flank-Geschichte hinkriegen.
Guck mal mal, rechte Seite.
Ich werde zum Squad Leader promotet werden.
Da war einer.
Tief.
Ich habe irgendwie diese schnelle...
Schneller Nachladen-Unlock für die Waffe.
Man merkt es ein bisschen.
Also, das scheint schon Effekt zu haben.
Ich dachte, ich kann ihn wiederbeleben.
Stop.
Overrated.
Debated.
Outdated.
Au!
Was ist hier los?
Alter.
Wo sind die Gegner?
Keine Gegner da.
Gegners.
Wo sind die Gegners?
Give Gegner, please.
Ich würde ihn jetzt gerne spotten, aber ich kann ja nicht.
Haha.
Das geht doch nicht.
Hat es das Gamer gedacht, dass...
Fuck.
Scheiß Balken.
Wo?
Scheiß Balken, ey.
Geht es irgendwann weiter mit den Programming-Streams?
Ja.
Ja, ja.
Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Jetzt muss man mal ein Meme-Bot mehr verwenden.
Ist die ganze Zeit an und ich verwende es nicht.
Voll verschenktes Potential.
Äh, bei dem spawne ich nicht.
Das zieht mir ein bisschen zu.
Hier.
RamonKS aus.
random. Ich muss mal hier weg. YOLO! Jump! Das ist in Low Settings. Ist auch immer so ein Problem, dass Gegner auf der Erde rumzappeln und man sie nicht sieht richtig. Ob sie leben, krabbeln, also ob sie tot sind, ob sie leben, noch krabbeln oder nicht.
Äh. Hä? Alter, dieses Game! The fuck? Rekt! Nein! Oh! MonkaS! Übelst MonkaS! Das wäre MonkaS, der MonkaS, ey!
Komm her! Letzten! Leute, so sieht es aus, wenn jemand zusammengeflickt wird.
Ich fliege dich zusammen, das ist fürs Wiederbeleben übelst komisch. Ich könnte nicht sagen, ich bashe dich jetzt weg.
Dann würde ich auch lieber aufstehen, als gebasht zu werden. Give ammo! Unter uns, hä? Hinter uns, hinter uns, hinter uns.
Nein, nein, nein, wir losten nicht, Bertha. Bertha wird nicht gelostet. Kleine! Ey, ich wollte grad.
FSK 18, 22.
Soll ich erzählen? Das geht ja nicht. Ähm. Was für ein Typ, ey. Lol! Alter! Was sind das für Gegner, ey? Was sind das für Gegner?
Ja, ähm, es hat gerade, ich habe gerade so aus dem Augenwinkel gesehen, dass jemand was von Unlocks geschrieben hat im Chat, wo ich sagen muss, ja, bin ich auch kein Fan von, wie sie das gemacht haben.
Dass du quasi Waffen unlockst irgendwie. Guck, du weißt, das ist so fail. Du weißt nicht, ob der Typ, eben hat er gerade noch gezappelt, ne? Du weißt nicht, ob der tot ist oder ob der, ob der krabbelt. Das ist so fail. Wer hat sich das ausgedacht? Alter, könnte ich mich darüber aufregen.
Ja, renn schön mit deinem Kopf rein, ob du kein Problem mit. Links. Oder auch nicht. Was ist das hier? Taugt das was?
Oh ne!
Ich brauche was anderes. Ich brauche was anderes. Gib, gib ordentliche Waffe. Ich gehe einfach zurück zum Muni-Ding. Hallo. Alter. Da ist ein Panzer hinter uns. Ich wusste gar nicht, ob ich hier rein verstecken kann. Hüpf, hüpf, hüpf. Krasser Soldat, hüpf hoch, please.
Jetzt kommt eine Granate. Ja, so sieht es aus. Wäsche, Wäsche, Wäsche, Wäsche, Wäsche. Hier ist nix. Hier ist nix.
Hier ist nix. Außer, außer von der Seite. Da ist was. Ja, Chris, du weißt doch. Die größten Hater sind die größten Fans. Ist so. Ist einfach so.
Die, die sich am meisten mit den Games beschäftigen, sind auch die, die sich am meisten mit den Games aufregen, weil sie die Games am besten kennen. Uh, der hier. Wo wir wieder bei Frontlinien sind, ne? Spawn hinter einem Tod.
Aber wobei das Argument jetzt in dem Fall ja gar nicht zutrifft. Es ist eine Beta.
Ist ja nix. Wo man ja wunderbar schon mal ausprobieren kann, ob man das Spiel sich holen will oder nicht.
Battlefield 1 Beta fand ich so schlimm, dass ich mir das Game nicht geholt hab.
Ich hab noch nicht mal den Code eingelöst, den ich hatte.
Wollte das Game nicht.
Jetzt letztens hat mir der Mesh noch einen Code gegeben. Da hab ich gesagt, okay, jetzt löse ich's ein.
Also sprich, wenn man noch, wenn man quasi noch, dann kann man ja nicht Nein sagen, ja.
Oh, ich spiel's nicht.
Battlefield 1. Sucker Gamer.
Was ist das denn?
Viel zu viel in dem Haus.
Fuck.
Und wer ist der Erste, der runterläuft und verreckt?
Ich.
Natürlich. Was sonst?
Übrigens, der Henkel Shelfhorst, der ist richtig gut da unten.
Der reckt sie alle.
Den Sinn dieser stationären Dinger, ich glaub, die verwendet keiner.
Was? Anton kann nicht lostet werden. Ich bin direkt dran.
Hä?
Fuck.
Sieht man, wie schlecht manche Leute sind, ey.
Du bist reulig.
Gegenüber ist einer.
Weiß nicht genau. Oh, da. Da, Schneiber, da. Was sonst? Ja, immer schön in der Ecke sitzen und schneibern.
Das können alle. Ich bin ein krasser Schneiper.
Jetzt sag ich, oh, ich bin so geil wie...
Was gibt's, was gibt's denn für geile Filmschneiper?
Äh.
Sagt, sagt mal einen. Es gibt doch bestimmt irgendwelche Filme mit geilen Snipern drinne.
Wollen alle geile Sniper sein hier, weil es sich da geil vorkommt.
So, mal Auto ausprobieren.
Nee.
Ach, da sitzt schon ein Typ am Turm.
Der tötet uns unbelegt an.
Was ist das denn?
Oh.
Das war ein Killstreak, übrigens.
Wir haben uns doch vorhin gefragt, wie ein Killstreak aussieht. So sieht ein Killstreak aus.
Jetzt müssen wir wissen, wie ein Killstreak aussieht.
So sieht ein Killstreak aus, ey.
What? The fuck?
Warum? Warum? Ey!
Wird der gerade gefickt, oder was?
Was ist das?
Cup of Pride?
Was, was, was, was, was macht der da auf dem Boden?
Übrigens, der Spawn ist auch übelst unfair, ne?
Oh, das wird die erste Runde mit 60 Kills? Nice.
Wäre das zwischendurch nicht so kacke gelaufen, hätten wir noch mehr.
Ich glaub 60, ich glaub 60er hatte ich noch nicht.
Spawn.
So, Leute, ich würde auch gerne mal Killstreaks machen.
Was ist denn die Taste für Killstreaks?
Das hat mir halt mal einer.
War das nicht V halten, oder so?
Das war so ganz merkwürdig.
Machen wir.
Wir, die fetten des Sektor.
Hier ist Karten aus.
Das, die sind, die, diese Karten aus
Dinger sind auch übelst rare.
Hier ist nichts. Warum, warum ist hier bitteschön
Karten aus? Hier ist nichts. Wisst ihr,
auf den Rushmaps in Bad Company, da hat man's ja
ungefähr noch versucht sinnvoll zu erklären,
wo Karten aus ist.
Da ging's dann halt einen Berg hoch und danach war Karten aus,
wo man offiziell nicht drüber kommt.
Aber was ist das hier?
Obwohl man ja vorher auf den Teil der Map konnte,
aus welchen Gründen, aus welch irgendwie
erdenkbaren Gründen kann man jetzt
nicht mehr, okay, ich darf nicht schratzen,
sollte man jetzt nicht mehr auf diese Map-Hälfte
können. Das ergibt überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Oh.
Das ist wieder so ein, so ein Ding.
Schreck. Wo ist, übrigens,
Leute, wo ist der Killfeed? Fällt mir
gerade auf. Wo ist der Kill, wo ist der
Killfeed?
Ernsthaft, wo ist der Killfeed? Ich seh ihn ja.
Wo ist denn der Killfeed?
Der ist weg.
Overrated, auch der. Kannst du an- und ausstellen?
Ah ja, okay, okay. Muss ich gleich mal machen.
Erinnert mich mal, please, mit
dran, dass ich Killfeed.
Wa- Alter!
Da- Fuck!
Was war das?
Das ist in dem Game, das sind so merkwürdige Dinger.
Hä?
Ich check das Game nicht.
Mein Problem ist, ich hab keine Muni mehr.
Legt hier noch was?
Alter, was ist mit der
Waffe los?
Das Game macht mich fertig.
Warum ist die, warum hat die sich jetzt verbogen?
Das Game macht mich wirklich
übelst,
übelst fertig im Kopf, äh.
Ich denk immer, das ist ein Kopf.
Aber ist das kein Kopf.
Gebaited, sag ich dazu nur.
Massiv,
massiver Gebait.
Damage machen Blitz.
Kann man das hier aufstellen?
Es ist so hakelig.
Hallo, stell doch mal please dein Ding hier auf.
Falls du was dran hast.
Ach, keine Ahnung.
Bin selbst verkackt.
Ach, Killstreaks kann man nur als Squadleader.
Ah.
Deswegen kann ich keine Killstreaks holen, okay.
Ah, das ist ja auch okay.
Das ist okay.
Das, ähm,
ist legitim. Das lass ich mir gefallen.
Wir flanken jetzt wieder unten rum.
Wie gehen wir denn in das Haus?
Das war ein guter Spot.
Äh.
Schreck mich nicht so.
Dachte wohl, was da oben los ist.
Das mit dem Bauen muss ich mir auch noch angucken.
Oh, Panzer.
Das mit dem Bauen muss ich mir auch noch angucken, wie das funktioniert.
Band.
Instant Band.
Ja, ich hab's jetzt gelesen.
Was hab ich denn noch überlesen im Chat?
Das hört sich ja so an, als hab ich jetzt die komplette,
als hab ich quasi
den kompletten Sinn des Games im Chat noch nicht gelesen.
Oh, hier ist ein Map aus.
Oh, fuck.
Bin arschgeschossen.
Was für Killstreaks alter Vierdrücken.
Hm.
Schlechter Debate.
Sehr schlechter Debate.
Vielleicht kriegen wir noch 70 Kills voll.
Ease.
Two Ease.
Ich steh hier grad irgendwie mit einem Gegnerspawn, ne?
Mehr oder weniger.
Warum die 70 kriegen wir noch?
Was?
Der hatte 15 Schuss drinne.
War das Spawn Immunity?
Das war Spawn Immunity, hä?
Das muss Spawn Immunity gewesen sein.
Naja, das war 100% Spawn Immunity.
War mehr.
Reds.
Spawn Protection war das.
Ja.
Ist halt geile Waffe auf Range.
Ah, Spawn Protection.
Spawn Protection 2k18.
Ease.
Wollen wir danach mal...
versuchen, ob wir ne Runde Conquest...
Ich mein, ich spiel halt nicht gerne Conquest, ne?
Muss ich dazu sagen.
Wow.
Ich spiel halt nicht gerne Conquest und
ich bin jetzt auch nicht sonderlich gut beim Conquest spielen.
Ich bin jetzt auch nicht sonderlich gut beim Conquest spielen.
Alter, was ist hier los?
Da können wir zumindest mal Rotterdam spielen.
Ja, Spawn Protection auf
Member Spawn verstehe ich eh nicht.
Wenn man, wenn man...
Seh ich wieder, Mr. Milchmann?
Wenn man halt kacke spawnt, ist man selbst dran.
Nein! Keine 70 Kills gepackt.
No.
größer als 70.
Ja, da ist auch was dran.
Kogas ruggelt.
Okay, wir spielen jetzt noch
Medik auf 10. Das machen wir heute noch.
Killfeed! Killfeed! Ja, perfekt, Leute.
Killfeed.
Ach ja, ich hab ja vergessen, dass man Options während dem Spawn
nicht machen kann.
...
Das war keine Spawn Protection?
Dann weiß ich auch nicht. Ich mein, der hat wirklich...
Das waren 15 Kugeln da so in dem Typ drin.
Oh. Jetzt ist die Frage...
Gameplay, ha?
Kill... Killlock...
Chat?
Also Chat machen wir mal an.
Chat muss man immer anmachen,
dass man ein bisschen Geflame sehen kann.
Ähm...
Killlock wird's wahrscheinlich sein.
Da ist schon ein bisschen
dummes Zeug zum Chat schreiben.
Ah, ich hätte die Waffe noch upgraden können.
Ich hab jetzt bestimmt genug Punkte.
Aber eigentlich will ich...
eigentlich will ich Medik Level 10 machen und dann...
Wir machen jetzt wieder unser Zug-Opening.
Ähm...
Ich werde jetzt Level 10 machen und dann...
Und dann MP40 unlocken.
Also MP40 unlocken...
MP40 unlocken und dann...
Warum hab ich denn so viele Zuschauer heute?
Ich mein, ich hab's noch nicht mal auf Twitter gepostet.
Jetzt kriegt eigentlich gar keiner mit.
Ähm... Kann jede Klasse bauen?
Wie seht ihr das?
Ich hab eigentlich gar keine Ahnung von dem Game.
Kann jede Klasse bauen?
Und wenn ja, wie baut man?
Hier an diesen Dingern kann man bauen, ne?
Ja, da oben mit dem Hammer.
Was, MP40 ist Kacke?
Echt? MP40 war in der Alpha übertrieben geil.
Also mega geil.
T drücken?
Ah, Minecraft-Style.
Wow!
Au, voll in your face.
Was ist hier los?
Muss nicht sterben.
Freimann Kopfgeschirr muss nicht sterben.
Jetzt.
Next.
Ah, shit.
Huge Place hätten das werden können.
Big Place. Aber leider sind wir verreckt.
Warum kann man mich nicht abonnieren?
Weil ich kein Twitch-Partner bin.
Kannst mich auf YouTube abonnieren.
Kannst du machen.
Wenn ich mal wieder was hochladen würde.
Squad sucked.
King. Squad King.
Geh mal.
Hallo?
Squad? King?
Battlefield. Dice.
Please, come on, bruh.
Okay.
Squad-System kaputt.
Spawn.
Spawnen. Jawoll.
Wie immersive ist das Game.
Das ist das immersivste Game, was ich je gespielt habe.
Vor allem Spawn-Bugs sind super immersive.
Das ist nämlich in echt auch passiert.
Man muss die Verzeichnungen von damals durchgucken.
Ha?
Da haben sich ganz viele Leute beschwert.
So 1942 rum.
Spawn-Bug.
Kam schon mal vor.
Hallo, sterben, please.
Was geht hier eigentlich gerade ab?
Kann mir das irgendjemand erklären?
Tango Sucker.
Beste Sounds.
Code 4 hat die besten Sounds, was das angeht.
Tango Sucker.
Oder?
Was gab's da sonst noch?
Irgendwas Arabisches, was ich nicht aussprechen kann.
Hayabina, Hayabina.
Hallo.
Geht's ab?
Jetzt werden sie aber gereckt, oder?
Okay, was auch immer.
Alter, hör auf zu brennen.
Brennen. Das gehört sich nicht.
Burn overrated.
Oh, hinter uns ist einer.
Was macht denn der da?
Hat es dem irgendeiner erlaubt, dahin zu stelzen?
Da unten ist er.
Ne.
Was hast du, Alter?
Komm her, gib her.
Was ist das?
SDG44. Nice.
Aber keine Muni dafür.
Oh, oh.
Ha!
Noob.
Ich brauch ne Waffe.
Give weapon, please.
So.
Hier gibt's nix. Keine Waffe.
Vielleicht beim
Schenkelhorst, oder wie der heißt.
Handgeschältforst.
Da gibt's bestimmt ne Waffe.
Ah, da ist was.
Waffe.
Hinwerfen. Heilen.
Gegner. Bashen.
So geht das, Leute. So geht das.
Oh!
Okay, der ist verreckt.
13-1. Nice.
An den Flaggen sind Munikisten, ja.
Ich weiß, ich seh die trotzdem im Eifer des Gefechts
immer nicht.
Spawnen, please. Spawnen.
Oh, wo sind wir denn hier gespawn?
Es war sehr gefährlich
hier zu spawnen.
Den Kopf.
Kann ich dir nicht ne Kiste geben?
Ah, guck mal, da ist ne Hehlkiste.
The enemy is winning?
Das sieht für mich nicht so aus,
als wint der enemy grade.
Der enemy kriegt grad auf den Sack.
Oder sieht das für euch so aus,
als wint der enemy?
Für mich sieht das aus, als kriegt der enemy
grad mega auf den Sack.
Guck mal. Ah, nice.
Schön drauf.
Der enemy kriegt grad mega,
einfach nur extrem auf den Sack.
Oh, nice. Muni.
Jetzt bin ich Spot wieder, ja.
Welcher Knopf ist das denn?
Also es kann mir keiner nachsagen,
dass in dem Game nicht geowned wird.
Ich brauch Muni. YOLO Muni.
Nice. Wieder hoch.
Wo ist er?
Den jucken enemy planes.
Komm her.
Moment, war der nicht hier?
Haha, Kollege, so nicht.
Ah, scheiße, da war noch einer.
Ich bin der Squadleader, ja.
B.
Echt B?
Wahrscheinlich bin ich nicht down.
Help, help, retz, please, alter.
Alter, ich bin der, der die Gegner killt.
Ihr müsst mich retzen.
Retzt mich doch. So schwer kann das doch nicht sein.
Alle ihr kleinen...
Ja, ja, ja, retzt mich, Alter.
Retzt mich, retzt mich.
Bast.
Please.
Was ist denn hier los? Ich muss hier weg.
So, B muss man drücken, okay, B.
B, passiert nichts.
B.
Debated.
Hinter uns.
Haha, die Noobs, ey.
Ins Gefecht.
So macht das doch Spaß.
Fuck, ich hab kaum noch Muni.
Kaum Muni.
Wieder Pistolenaction. Pistolenaction ist immer das Beste.
Ah, ich hab wieder Muni. Jawoll.
26, 3.
Jetzt werden sie geschreckt.
Die Gegner sind so schlecht.
Ja, nice.
Bau, Bau, Bau, Ding.
Perfekt. Wie in das T.
Ja, hallo. Lass mich bauen.
Please, bauen.
Next. So, jetzt bauen wir mal.
Was? Minecraft Simulator.
Hallo, bauen.
Bauen?
Ich bin zu dumm für das Game.
Ich kann nur killen.
Ich kann sonst nix in dem Game. Guck mal.
Ich kann nicht bauen.
Warum nicht?
Das ist so mir. Warum kann ich nicht bauen?
Leute, baut.
Ich kille. Das ist gut.
Ich kille und retze.
Wow.
Da ist schon gebaut. Achso.
Ach, Mark kann man... Ja, das ist ja...
Woher weiß man, wo man Wände bauen kann und wo man nur Sandstärke bauen kann?
Hm.
Ich muss hier mal kurz weg.
Ist mir ein bisschen zu...
...gefährlich.
Da, wo Dice will, baut man ja. Ich seh's.
Moment.
Ich war hinter dem Ding.
Der kommt hier gleich raus.
Da ist noch einer dahinter. Achtung.
Oh.
Fuck.
Das war anders geplant.
Das war nicht so geplant, Leute.
Ich wollte es eigentlich rauswerfen.
MonkaS.
Massive MonkaS.
Boah, ey. Was ist hier los?
Ja, versteck dich.
Ich will mit Ammo spawnen.
Perfekt.
So ist das gut.
Jetzt kommt krass Flank-Action.
Rekt.
SMGs sind toll auf Range, ne?
Echt. So muss das sein.
32-4. In your face.
Muss klatschen, muss es.
Dazu gibt's dann eigentlich auch nur noch
zu sagen...
Rotterdam.
Ja, Medic Level 10.
Die Runde mach ich noch fertig.
Das ist ja noch nicht fertig.
Das war jetzt nur Attack.
Moment mal.
Ich hab eingebaut, dass man den beschleunigen kann.
Coggers?
Coggers Speed.
Coggers.
Genauso wie Lull und...
Lull 4D.
Es ruckelt leider,
weil so viel im Hinterkopf läuft.
Omega Coggers, ja.
Ja, linke Seite.
Klar, was sonst?
Wir machen wieder unser Opening, wo man nicht genau weiß,
wie es wird.
Es kann gut sein oder nicht gut sein.
Ich sag euch, das Opening kann gut sein
oder nicht gut sein.
Jetzt ist es grad ganz gut.
Out of Ammo? Oh ne.
Haha.
Boah. Was war das denn?
Moment.
Der hat mich mit der gleichen Waffe gekillt, die ich hab.
Hat sich das so angefühlt,
als hätte er mehr als einmal geschossen?
Hat sich das jetzt so angefühlt,
In your face war das.
Lass dich mal nicht beschießen.
Kulmikus.
Ja, okay, dann nicht.
Spawnen.
Aber 6-3-5, die wären übelst krass
gereckt für da die Runde, ey.
Oh man.
Toxic Chat.
Don't.
This isn't Overwatch.
So, genug trash talked im Chat.
Weiter geht's.
Alter, ich will hier drauf lassen,
damit diese scheiß Animation funktionieren.
Animation of Doom.
Hier oben ist übrigens Top Spot.
Habt ihr ja, ne?
Super Spot.
Wenn man halt Gegner hat.
Ist aber keiner. Wo sind die Gegner?
YOLO Charge über die Lok.
Sag mal, ist das
grad Spawnrape oder so?
Kann das sein?
Spawnrape?
Das sieht mir so ein bisschen
nach Spawnrape aus, wenn ich ehrlich bin.
So minimal.
Komm her, schratz dich.
Move dich.
Das ist echt gut
programmiert, ja.
Ich weiß auch nicht, wie es ist beim fünften Spiel
auf, oh ne, warte mal, warte mal.
Ist es das fünfte Spiel auf Frostbite Engine?
Bad Company 1, Bad Company 2,
Battlefield 3, Battlefield 4,
Hardline, Battlefield 1.
Hab ich was vergessen? Das ist das sechste, siebte Spiel auf Frostbite.
Oder? Hab ich was vergessen?
Quickmuffs?
Highspeedmuffs?
Suche Gegner.
Gegner nicht vorhanden.
Ah, die Gegner haben schon alles eingenommen da hinten.
Okay.
Wir spawncampen, während die Gegner die halbe Map erobern.
Das ist kein Ding, das ist doch easy.
So. Nicht in die Richtung laufen.
Nicht in die Richtung laufen.
Nie in die Richtung laufen, wo die Gegner erwarten,
dass man langläuft.
Sonst kann man sie nicht own.
Dann in die Richtung, wo die Gegner nicht erwarten,
wo man ist.
Kann ja immer mal passieren.
Dann wird's, dann klatscht's.
Haben die eigentlich was auf mein dummes Zeug
geschrieben?
Ne.
Pay to win?
What the fuck?
Was labern die Leute wieder?
Komplett random
die Diskussion im Chat wieder.
Ne, wir gehen unten lang.
Wir gehen unten lang, linke Seite.
Wir gehen linke Seite lang und hoch.
Bertha ist getaked.
Die Bertha wurde geta- oh.
Wow.
Kann das sein, dass dieses Jubels
unflame?
Wie dein Chat abgeht.
Gelb.
Monka Toss, ja.
Richtig Monka Toss.
Ich will die bashen an B.
Guck mal, das find ich jetzt halt auffällig.
Man spawnt B
und man spawnt
da. The fuck?
Ich will an B spawnen.
B ist
da.
Ich spawne 150 Meter
weit weg.
I don't fuck.
Ich will an B spawnen.
Und ich B plus 150 Meter.
Bertha is lost.
Gehen wir jetzt mal vor, würde ich sagen.
So nicht.
Next please.
Wir flanken jetzt.
Fuck, fuck, fuck.
Wir haben uns feiern müssen.
In SDG 44 hast du nicht so
klasse Chance.
Fair aimed. Pech.
Die Wehrmacht
konnte auch nicht in Moskau spawnen.
Aber die Wehrmacht konnte auch nicht an B spawnen.
Das Problem
ist ja, dass du gar nicht spawnen kannst.
Was ehrlich
gesagt ziemlich sackt.
Muss man ja schon mal ehrlich sagen.
Moment.
Die Phase ist vorbei.
Next.
Ich geh mal auf die andere Seite.
So wie gefühlt das halbe Team
auch.
Wir ärgern den Typ jetzt mal ein bisschen.
Ich find das immer geil.
So die Flamer noch ein bisschen ärgern.
Lass die noch ein bisschen mehr flamen.
Oh hier ist aus.
Voll in die Fresse.
Wo ist der nächste?
Wat? Wie sind die denn hier durchgekommen?
Ich geh ja schon zurück.
Ist gut.
Bin ja schon auf dem Weg.
Kannst du mal verrecken.
Nope.
Verrecken ist outdated.
Jetzt holen wir mal
den Anton wieder.
Oh.
Machen wir nicht.
Spawnen wir mal hier hinten.
Dann holen wir es wieder.
Was hat er noch geschrieben?
Reflamed.
Null.
King the Veteran.
Kann ja nicht sein.
Da ist der King.
Der kann nicht LMG werden.
Der Anton ist wieder uns.
Jawoll.
Aber jetzt ist die Bertha weg.
Was sagt Bertha beste?
Da.
M.
SMG Sniper Action.
Was ist das?
Animation!
Mich fuckt das Game so unglaublich ab manchmal.
Ich konnte nichts machen.
Animation!
Das nervt mich.
Warum?
Was sollen diese Animationskrütze da?
Da kannst du dich überhaupt nicht bewegen dabei.
Geht gut.
Genau.
Wenn du gut gittest, dann wird die Animation schneller.
Das war jetzt Fail.
Aber trotzdem ey.
Diese Animation. Alter.
Der Typ der muss sich den Arsch abretzen übrigens.
Mit 18.
Das Team ist mir übrigens übelst reich ey.
Das ist aufregend.
Das Game fühlt sich so gewollt und nicht gekonnt an allen Stellen.
RIP.
Anton wieder weg.
Moment seh ich das richtig?
Almost taken.
Ist auch geil.
Au.
Raus hier.
Zu wenig Leben.
Der ist sehr aktiv der Gute.
Next.
Oben rechts.
Ja SMG Range.
Fenster? Ist hier ein Fenster?
Na Aim.
Massive Na Aim.
Aber SMG Range ist auch kacke.
Alter.
Wie das ruckelt.
Das ganze Bildschirm springt hin und her.
Ah ja.
Weil der Matt dazu gerade was schreibt im Chat.
Ähm.
Jaja ich hab mitgekriegt, dass ähm.
Das Vine jetzt quasi in Steam vorliegen ist.
Wobei es ist ja nicht Vine.
Es ist dieser.
Es ist Vine.
Also es ist ein Vine Fork mit ein paar speziellen Patches.
Plus nem DirectX zu Vulcan.
Vulcan.
Vulcan? Wie spricht man das aus?
Rapper.
Also sprich ähm.
Eine Zwischenschicht die DirectX Aufrufe zu Vulcan übersetzt.
Und ähm dementsprechend dann mit dem passenden Treiber auch auf Linux läuft.
Und das funktioniert viel besser als man denkt.
Also ich dachte auch am Anfang.
Lull wieder so ein Kack Rewind.
Was nicht richtig läuft.
Aber das läuft wirklich nicht schlecht.
Du hast ein paar Grafik Klitsches und so.
Aber bei weitem nicht so viele.
Wie man sich das.
Ja das ist echt nicht schlecht.
Aber an dem Game weiß man nicht wo was herkommt.
Eine Sache.
Die mir hier auch auffällt ist.
Ähm.
Ich vergleichs jetzt mal mit einer anderen Beta.
Beziehungsweise Battlefield Alpha.
Ist der Typ hier drinne?
Ich vergleichs mal mit der Bad Company.
2 Alpha.
Ich hab die Alpha.
Von Release der Alpha.
Bis zum Schließen der Server.
Gefühlt 24-7 gespielt.
Ohne Pause.
Es gab eine Map. Das war Port Valdas.
Es gab einen Spielmodus. Das war Rush.
Fertig.
Ich konnte das spielen.
Keine Ahnung.
Ich war traurig als die Beta vorbei war.
Sag ich mal so.
Nach 2 Stunden Battlefield 5.
Jetzt bin ich schon zu langweilig.
Und zu Rage.
Anfällig.
Und es sind.
Es ist gar keine einzelnen Riesenpunkte.
Wo ich sagen würde.
Es ist so eine Kombination aus allem.
Das Spiel wirkt einfach an vielen Stellen.
So wie gewollt und nicht gekonnt.
Also ganz vielen Sachen.
Auch diese Kletteranimationen zwischendurch.
Warum?
Das ist das was mir wirklich.
Ich habs ja ein paar mal heute gesagt.
Was mir an dem Game wirklich den Spaß verdirbt.
Warum ich mir.
Also was der Grund werden könnte.
Warum ich mich nicht kaufe.
Diese Animationskack ist wirklich so nervig.
Was?
Weil ich.
Gehen wir mal da ran.
In your face.
Next.
Die wollen flanken von links.
Ich kenn die.
Immer von links flanken.
Oder auch nicht.
Okay die haben auch nicht geflankt.
Aber meistens flanken sie von links.
Komm her.
Spritze in den Arm.
Auf gehts.
Wie in echt.
Ich bin total witzig.
Fuck.
Aber upgrade.
Was.
Upgrading.
Are we?
Ich hoffe das stimmt so.
Es wird ja durch die Animation nicht taktischer.
Es wird dem Spieler bloß Kontrolle entzogen.
Und sollte einem Spiel.
Also einem First Person Spiel vor allem nicht grade.
Also grade einem First Person Spiel.
Grade so sein dass der Spieler immer Kontrolle hat.
Wozu gibt es.
Es widerspricht.
irgendwie quasi
First Person, so nach dem Motto
du bist der Spieler, so aus Ego-Sicht
und dann kannst du nichts machen, weil das Spiel
sagt, nein, jetzt kommt eine Kletteranimation.
Ich finde, das widerspricht dem
dem kompletten
ja, dem kompletten
Ansatz.
Kollege, du hast jetzt gebasht.
Rekt!
Richtig reingefahren hier.
Oh, Tür zu.
Warum auch immer.
H-Zorn, Fire.
Warum?
Du bist ja ein richtiger Scharfschützer.
Ist das historisch korrekt,
dass die das untereinander gesagt haben?
Sonst ist meine Immersion direkt weg.
Echt?
Echt, recht.
Der kommt jetzt, guck.
Oh, fuck.
Jetzt hat er mich outplayed. Das ist der gleiche Typ, keine Ahnung.
Mein Gedanke war eigentlich,
der läuft jetzt links und dann war er nicht links,
dann kommt er rechts, aber er war weiter rechts.
Das hat er gut gemacht.
Ja, das sind so kleine Dinge, wo man immer noch sieht, dass
es hier um Basics geht eigentlich.
YOLO-Nade.
Wo sind eigentlich Gegner?
Die sind auf der anderen Seite, ne?
Ja.
Wir müssen, ich muss mal auf der rechten Seite mal reenforcen.
Alter, von jeder Seite, überall, irgendwo.
Du Schwachmard, oh, das ist ja, das ist Burn, ey.
Krass.
Da ist, da ist aber der Bann direkt raus, wenn einer sagt, du Schwachmard.
Das geht ja nicht.
Ich kann alles sagen, aber du Schwachmard, das geht nicht.
Was sollen denn die Kinder denken, das Spiel spielen?
Und ja, das Spiel werden trotzdem wieder viele Kinder spielen.
Genau, sie, Black Ops 8.
Fünf.
Hack, Band, Hack, Wallhack.
Ich hab dich gesehen.
Ah, fuck.
Ich dachte, der Vision noch.
Oh, it's on fire.
War ein Flausen.
Das Spiel ist lang, war heilig.
So, mal gucken, ob ich jetzt ordentliches Medic-Level gekriegt hab.
Oh, ich hab, ich hab ehrlich gesagt, keine Lust auf Conquest, ey.
Ich bin mal gespannt, wie der Battle-Royale-Modus wird.
Squad Easy, jawohl, Wester Squad.
Squad Easy.
Oh, kein Level abgekriegt.
Nvidia Highlights.
Passiert nix.
Null.
Geiler Knopf.
So, wir spielen jetzt noch ne Runde, dass Medic-Level 10 ist.
Und dann...
Oh, dann spielen wir echt mal...
Ich, ich werd wahrscheinlich...
Direkt quitten, ey, wenn ich Conquest spiele.
Conquest.
Warum machen die nicht einfach die neue Map für...
Guck mal, vorhin sind wir vorne gespawnt, jetzt spawnen wir hinten, obwohl wir an der gleichen Stelle gespawnt sind.
Übrigens, danke für die ganzen Follows, ich hab's jetzt nicht auf und falls...
Äh, hab ich, hab ich ne Donation oder so ver... übersehen?
Ich hoffe nicht.
Ich muss gleich mal gucken, dann.
Was?
Ist off?
Warum ist Instant Replay off?
Nvidia, come on, brah.
Nvidia, lol.
Nvidia in current...
Current DIY, lol.
Bam.
Ich will bauen.
Kann man hier bauen?
Haha.
Ich baue.
Öh!
Ich baue nicht.
Fuck!
What?
Ah, der ist drüber gehüpft.
Ding, ding.
Ding, ding, ding.
Was macht der denn hier oben?
Lass mich...
Pfff.
Tja, Kollege.
So funktioniert das nicht.
Spornen, jawoll.
Bester Spornpunkt.
Äh, Mann.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh.
Come on, brah.
Ich sag euch, bestes Opening hier an den Zügen.
Ihr könnt's mir glauben.
Gegner?
Gibt's nicht.
Ah, ich muss nachladen.
Äh, Munikiste da.
Munikiste.
Come on, brah.
Na ja.
Da kommt was grüpft zu mir.
Oder auch nicht.
Guck mal, was hier vorne links passiert.
Maxi, machst du es in dem Alter so zu hinten?
Übung.
Lull.
Boah.
STG auf Einzelschuss ist ganz gut.
Richtig.
STG Einzelschuss ist die beste Waffe.
Fuck.
Moment.
Das ist der Typ.
Da will ich bestimmt eins spawnen.
Außerdem hitte ich nicht so.
Es sind bloß ultra viele Noobs in dem Game.
Also ich sag euch, das Game könnte das übelste Own-Game werden, wenn halt so die nervigen
Dinger rauskommen.
Oder halt nicht drin sind.
So wie diese ultra langen Kack-Animationen.
Dann wird das Game, dann wird das Gebärsche schlechthin.
Ja.
Ein bisschen mehr Muni vielleicht noch.
Ich retz dich mal, Alter.
Komm mal her.
Warte.
Oh, oh.
Da kann ich nicht runter.
Heil dich mal.
Jawoll.
Runter.
Flank.
Links.
Achtung, da kommt einer.
Ah.
Nicht stecken bleiben.
Nicht stecken bleiben im Zug.
Wieder hoch auf den Zug.
Animation.
Please.
Ich find's ja lustig, ne?
Ich sag's dir.
Ich sag's dir schon immer mit Ansage, was jetzt ein guter Play ist.
Aber das Spiel lässt mich nicht.
Ich will runter.
Das ist so schlimm.
Das hat überhaupt keinen Fluss.
Das macht mich fertig.
Wisst ihr, du weißt, was ein guter...
Du weißt, was ein guter Play ist, aber das Game lässt dich nicht.
Du weißt, dass ich da bin.
Was ist das hier?
The fuck?
ich meine es ist das was wir haben vorhin durchgezählt das siebte frostbite game was
ich schreib mal was mit dlc in den chat wie meinst du das meinst du in ingame chat oder was
wieso triggert das die leute wenn man dlc schreibt flankerino das geht jetzt in die
hose ich hab's ich hab's im gefühl es geht die hose was dlc dlc was dlc wird zensiert warum was
ist denn dlc jetzt so gefährlich warum darf man dlc nicht sagen das funktioniert echt nicht und
vor allem richtig gut zensiert ja nicht einfach nur
und vor allem richtig gut zensiert ja nicht einfach nur
so keine chance ich retze dich hinter uns was kann es sein wenn es der typ da oben drauf kommt
man da hoch also ich stelle da jetzt mal hoch lollo er kennt mich jetzt wenn ich leider auch
kommt aber schon tot in bed company 2 hat schon mal falsch aufgemacht
ist
einzige
rip
hier
also
guck mal wo ist der Arthur
accumulator
auf der
n Butter
du liking
ich habe
heute
hängen
satt impacted
total
du nicht
aber so über die dedioren
Ahnung.
Ein Titanfall ist bestimmt in keiner anderen
Sprache ein Fluchwort. Das ist einfach
Konkurrenzwut und
E-Fall.
Geil.
Wow.
Shit.
Guck mal, 3 ist 5. Der Typ geht ab, ey.
Endlich mal einer, der auch.
Es wird wegen
Tits...
Ich mein,
es kann durchaus Wörter geben, wo
Titel...
Wird nicht zensiert?
Wird auch nicht zensiert.
Okay.
Wörter ist weg.
Die Animation ist auch
so geil, ne, wieder gewesen.
Endlich mal eine Runde, wo ich ja alles bashen
muss. Habt ihr den
Trailer von diesem einen... Wie hieß das Game?
World War
3?
3 oder so? Habt ihr den Trailer davon gesehen?
Also, quasi,
was so ein bisschen wie Battlefield ist von den Klassen her,
halt, ähm,
in dem modernen Setting.
What? Ah, da war noch mehr.
Ja, das kann schon
sein, dass es wegen Tipps
zensiert wird, aber...
Warum?
Suche Sinn.
Ich mein, es gibt halt Wörter, in denen
T-I-T vorkommt.
Ah.
Jetzt krieg ich aber gerade auf die Fresse,
nach den letzten Runden, so übelst geil.
Und...
Unten ist besser.
Kann da einer
Uptime im Chat machen? Ich will wissen, wie lange ich schon
on bin. Ich merk's langsam,
dass ich ein bisschen müde wär.
Also, das ist müde. Nicht müde in Form von
Schlafen, sondern von...
Battlefield.
Flank Action. Flank Reno.
Gucken, ob das klappt.
Hätte ich mehr rausholen können.
Wären sie gestorben, nachdem ich draufgeschossen hätte, wäre...
Hätte ich vier Leute gekillt.
Also,
das war mein Fehler.
Ich hätte ein Stückchen höher gemusst.
Aber...
Der Soldat ist halt nicht in der Lage gewesen, da...
Krasse...
Na, nicht Elite.
Ja, der...
In...
In neueren Battlefields sind's ja alles so Elite-Soldaten, aber hier im Zweiten Weltkrieg kann ich mir sogar...
Ja, wenn...
Wenn halt dann der Typ nicht berghoch kommt, dann kann er auch nix machen.
Okay, wir stellen jetzt wieder unten rum.
In der Hoffnung, dass wir nicht gebasht werden.
Eins! MonkaS!
Ich will nicht bauen, ich will dich nicht heilen!
Ach, das war mein Dude.
Kann man da hochklettern oder kriegt man dann direkt auf den Sack?
Was?
Hoh!
Alter, hab ich euch weggereckt.
Rekt des Todes, ey!
Damit habt ihr jetzt nicht gerechnet, ne?
Was ist denn das hier?
Braucht das was?
Ey, das ist kacke.
Poggers, echt Poggers war das.
Das ist ziemlich sackig, das...
Das Geschütz.
Bleib jetzt hier, ich mach das jetzt wieder.
0815 Casual, die spielen ja so.
So. Easy.
Oh, ist das Immersive.
Immersivste Game aller Zeiten.
Immersive. Yeah.
Das ist Immersive.
Guck mal, wie geil ich bin, wenn ich da jetzt schießen kann, ohne dass mir was passiert.
Casual FPS am Start.
So, was geht, Leute?
Wir verlieren Objectives, mir egal. Ich will lieber am Geschütz sitzen bleiben.
Ich bin voll immersed. Ich bin voll immersed.
Ist der dumm, oder was?
Ich werd nicht weggebombt. Ich bin Casual FPS.
Da kann das nicht passieren.
Oh.
Okay, oder doch.
Weiter.
Achtung. Animation diesmal.
Animation, please.
Oh, ich hätte wenden können, die sind hier unten.
Sind sie aber nicht.
Krasse World War 2 Experience.
Massive.
Huge place. Huge.
Huge World War 2 Experience.
Huge. Huge World War 2 Experience.
So, wir gehen da rüber. Besser. Scheint's gerade ein bisschen Unterstützung zu brauchen.
Auf welcher Sense TPI spielst du?
20% Ingame. Also, 360 ist in dem Game nur ungefähr ein Dreiviertel-Mauspad.
In den anderen Games spiele ich meistens 360 auf dem ganzen Mauspad.
Und TPI ist 600. Ich glaube, 600. 800?
Let's please.
Was ist denn so das Standard-Setting? 600 oder 800?
Was man so standardmäßig in einem Maus-Treiber auswählen kann.
Man kann immer auswählen, 1200 kann man immer auswählen.
Ich bin übrigens getrappt. Ich kann mir das bewegen.
Ich glaube, 600 war's, ne?
Alter, was geht denn hier gerade ab? Ach, das ist das Flugzeug.
800. Ja, dann sind es 800. 800.
800, ja. Also, gerade geht nix, ne?
Jetzt werde ich auch noch überfahren.
Kann das sein, dass der gerade überfahren wurde, weil er mich beretzen wollte?
Ja, 800. 820% Ingame.
Ich finde es auch ganz wichtig, dass man die klare Animation, ne, die Animation ist das Schlimmste in dem Game.
Höchstens das Allerschlimmste. Das, warum ich es mir wahrscheinlich nicht holen werde.
Ich krieg, ich, also, ich bin so tiltet durch die ganzen Animationskram.
Ja, also, normale Games habe ich immer so eingestellt, dass ich auf dem Mauspad hier halt 360 auf dem Mauspad habe.
Aber Battlefield ein bisschen schneller, weil das halt ein bisschen mehr, ach, ist schon.
Battlefield muss ein bisschen mehr rumgucken.
Ich habe immer ein schlechtes Gewissen, irgendwie, ne?
Wenn ich Streamern habe und dann ist mal eine Runde zwischendurch, wo ich sacke, weil es geht jetzt ja, ne?
Also, es ist absolut scheiße.
Denke ich mir immer, oh, das ist kacke, das will doch keiner sehen, so ein Scheiß, oh.
Das Ball steht auch, ne?
Geht auch nicht.
Deswegen habe ich so Fähigkeiten.
Fail-Play ist in Overwatch immer aufgeregt.
Du machst den Fail-Play und jeder sieht's.
Gut geplanter Flank, leider Gegner aufgepasst.
Kann man nix machen.
Wir machen jetzt mal was anderes.
Wir gehen jetzt die rechte Seite und hoffen, da steht keiner.
Das Game wird generell keiner sehen, ja.
Ich weiß, ich weiß, dass du es nicht so gemeint hast, das kommt uns, aber, ähm, ich könnte das verstehen,
weil es macht mir auch keinen sonderlich großen Spaß beim Spielen.
Das kommt ja noch dabei.
Alter, verpiss dich.
Ich wollte eine andere Seite flanken.
Jetzt, Achtung, jetzt.
Rechts ist was, ich muss rüber.
Fuck.
Hallo, Köttner.
Aber ich kann's verstehen, ey, das ist, ist nicht so das geilste, ne?
Und was ich halt überhaupt nicht verstehe, ist,
so, ähm, was ich halt überhaupt nicht verstehe, ist,
dass sie es Movement-mäßig und so, das haben sie ja schon hingekriegt.
Also, entweder kommt man mal zu, sagen wir mal, Battlefield, also zu BC2,
wo es halt dieses, das war ja das letzte Battlefield ohne diese, diese komischen, ne,
ohne diese komischen Kletter- und Gedöns-Animationen drinne.
Da hat das Movement auch gut funktioniert.
Obwohl es schon ein bisschen träger war in Bad Company 2.
Äh.
Hüpp, Animation, fick dich, Dice.
Alter.
Oh, regt mich das auf.
Alter, regt mich das auf.
Dass du kommst doch nicht aus Animationen raus.
Der klettert, du, du bist mitten im Fight und er fängt einfach rum zu klettern an.
Was soll das denn?
Seit wann sind die Battlefield-Spieler eigentlich alle so negativ geworden?
Seit die Spiele nicht mehr dementsprechend, was man sich wünscht.
Ganz einfach.
Ich meine, das ist doch eine total dämliche Entscheidung.
Dass du eine uncancelbare Animation abspielst von drei Sekunden mitten im Fight.
Und dass jemand den Sprungknopf drückt in dem Spiel, ist jetzt ja nix so unwahrscheinliches.
Ich hab keinen Bock, ey, das regt mich auf.
Cutgame.
Hoffentlich bin ich danach Magic Level 10 und hab schon mein Beta-Exp erfüllt.
So schlecht fand ich Hardline gar nicht.
Ganz ehrlich.
Hardline hat das Setting, weil Hardline war scheiße.
Das hat mir überhaupt nicht gefallen.
Und auch, dass es keinen Rush gab.
Also an sich, Hardline hatte auch schon seine Probleme.
Aber rein von den Waffen her und von wie sie es gespielt hat, würde ich Hardline, dieser Shitshow hier, 500 Mal vorziehen.
Zeit für Kirby-Musik, richtig.
Richtig.
Detilt-Modus.
Ich hab gehört, ich krieg den noch weg.
Ist es das Spiel oder wenn es eine schlechte Beta ist?
Also, im Kern denke ich nicht, dass das...
Ich mein, du hast in der Beta jede Menge Bugs.
Wie diesen Spawn-Bug und sowas.
Okay.
Das lass ich, das sag ich.
Habt ihr mich einmal heute über den Spawn-Bug zum Beispiel meckern, oder?
Ich hab ihn ja auch nicht.
Okay.
Ich glaube, ähm, das sind grundlegende Entscheidungen, die mich abfacken an dem Game.
Ich geh mal rüber.
Ja, gut.
Ja, die sind schon drüben.
Wenn die Animationen richtig funktionieren würden...
Ich weiß, ich weiß nicht, das Problem ist halt, dass es die Animationen gibt.
Also, ja, es ist einmal kacke, dass sie nicht richtig funktionieren, wenn du an der Stelle kletterst und er klettert nicht und du musst erst 50 Mal spammen, bis er klettert.
Das ist blöd.
Dass allerdings zwischendurch Animationen kommen, in Situationen, wo du sie nicht brauchen kannst, das ist halt das eigentliche Problem.
Und die funktionieren ja dann leider.
Und...
Die sind halt einfach total deplatziert.
Oh!
Das ist das erste Mal heute, dass ich Muni gekriegt hab.
Also, so mit Ansage.
Wie sieht's eigentlich da drüben aus?
Muss man da rüber?
Ja, was machen wir, Feldwebel?
Erzähl.
YOLO machen wir.
Ha, ich dachte...
YOLO machen wir, hab ich gesagt.
Kann man abrollen wie im Trailer?
Möglich.
Ich wüsste nicht, wie.
Du-du-du-du, du-du-du-du-du-du-duu...
Übrigens, wer's nicht feststellt, das ist eine andere Kirby-Musik als das letzte Mal.
Das letzte Mal hatten wir einen Kirby Gourmet Race oder sowas.
Und heute haben wir den Kirby Green Zone Mix.
Jaja, ein Green Zone Mix.
Hinter mir ist was... Ich weiß, dass hinter mir was ist übrigens.
Ich wollte erst mal Entdeckung.
Guck mal, die sind hinter uns.
hinter uns es gibt auch wieder mal überhaupt keine frontlinie hier
frontlines im 2k18 omega lol
die better
was was trifft mich
weg gesprayt ist das rasch das ist das ist rasch für arme es ist opera
operations oder wie das heißt das ist ein kack rush modus also es ist nicht es
ist nicht halt es ist nicht rasch das ist nicht das ist ich weiß nicht was es
ist operations aber es ist kacke also mit map zonen wo man sich fragt wo die
herkommen und ich weiß nicht an dem spiel weg einfach so viel
geworden
wollte und ich gekonnt dass aber an dafür ist die beta da das muss ich sagen
kommt dann sagen kann
ist grundsätzlich was oder ist grundsätzlich nix warum ist der hier oben
gerade rum gezapelt der war das ok ford
vortrag ist nix also ich bin der meinung dass public das beste battle royale ist
apa
auch nichts für mich.
Also rein vom Gesamtpaket her
und vom Ablauf her
finde ich, ist PUBG das beste Battle Royale Game.
Aber ist nicht mein Fall.
Das Battle Royale Game, was mir am meisten
Spaß gemacht hat, war bisher Realm Royale.
Allerdings, die haben es ja auch wieder komplett
verschissen.
Habe ich jetzt uninstalled
mittlerweile.
Da wollte er mich schneibern, der Gude.
Man sieht irgendwie nichts.
Man sieht nichts.
Und hier ist die Map zu Ende.
Wir campen jetzt hier einfach.
Ich kann nicht campen.
Ich kriege das in keinem Game hin.
Ich bin nicht campfähig.
Ich bin nicht
fähig zu campen.
Unmöglich.
Von hinten!
Da sind aber ganz viele Leute gewesen.
Was ist mit Realm Royale passiert? Sie haben es verkackt.
Sie haben es zum Beispiel, sie haben Autorifles eingeführt
und so komische Dinger.
Wie eine Zeit lang OP war. Sie haben dieses
Crafting System, was eigentlich das Game ausgezeichnet
hat. Also wo
du musstest quasi.
Du musstest quasi aggressiv
spielen in dem Game.
Du musstest ran, weil du quasi
du hast Crafting
Material von gekillten Gegnern gebraucht.
Sonst konntest du deine Waffen nicht
craften. Das heißt, die Leute, die aggressiv
gespielt haben und Fights gewonnen haben, hatten
immer bessere Chancen als Leute, die rumgecampt
haben.
Alter, das ist doch schlimm.
Hast du eigentlich
mittlerweile eine Lösung gefunden, dass man nichts
in Bash Copy pasten kann?
Hä?
Was meinst du, Evoli?
Warum kannst du in Bash nichts Copy
pasten?
Da kann ich mich jetzt nicht mehr dran erinnern, auf was du dich
beziehst.
Gibt es das um die Ecke erschossen werden?
Das ist in dem Game...
Ich denke schon, dass es das gibt.
Man merkt es in dem Game nicht so sehr.
Wobei das jetzt nichts
Gutes ist für das Game, weil man merkt es
in dem Game nicht, weil es keine Frontlinie gibt.
Du kannst jederzeit von jeder...
Also du kannst jederzeit von jeder
Richtung angeschossen werden.
Deswegen merkst du es nicht, ob man um die Ecke
geschossen wird, so gut, so, so schnell.
NA-Aim.
Es war eine Kombination aus NA-Aim und, ähm,
tja, NA-Aim.
Und rumgeruckelt von Gegnern,
die sich komisch bewegt haben.
Das wird wahrscheinlich die letzte Runde.
Das Game
nervt mich.
Wo sind sie denn?
Was?
Voll in die Eier.
Eine gute Neuerung
ist auch diese Geschichte mit,
dass man leichter Kills als,
also auch Assists als Kills, also leichter
angerechnet bekommt.
The British thought that
they were worthy opponents.
That mistake has cost them dearly.
With our lines
intact, our forces can safely
move into a more strategic location
in the mountains.
We will prevail.
So, mal gucken,
ob das jetzt für Level 10 gereicht hat. Wahrscheinlich.
Keine hinten und vorne nicht.
Best Squad? Wir sind immer Best Squad.
Jede Runde sind wir Best Squad. Ne, sind wir gar nicht.
Easy. Easy Squad
hat gewonnen.
Immer Easy Squad.
Ja. Oh! Oh! Jawoll!
Level 10.
Didi.
Wir sind Level 10.
Ich würde das gern quitten.
Gibt es das automatische
Leben, wenn man an einer Wand steht? Ja, allerdings.
Funktioniert das manchmal nicht.
Wie im Prinzip seit Anfang an.
Sind wir jetzt eigentlich Level 10
gewesen oder waren wir kurz vor Level 10?
Steht ja hier nirgendswo, ne? Wäre ja cool, wenn das
irgendwo stehen würde.
Doch, 10. Wir sind 10.
Dann anlocken wir jetzt die MP40.
Geht das? Kann ich einfach
die Typen... Ha!
Geil! Man kann die Typen
hier aus dem Squad rausklingen.
So richtig dumm.
Ich kenne die Typen überhaupt nicht.
Okay, jetzt hängt das Game.
Das war keine gute Idee.
Ich mache das Game halt aus.
Ich gehe wieder an.
Ja, Evoli, das kommt alles noch.
Die müssen das erst annehmen.
Ja, ich weiß, dass die das annehmen müssen.
Ich wollte eigentlich abbrechen.
Das ist auch schon wieder ein Fail, dass man das nicht machen kann.
Wenn die sagen so, ups, wollte ich doch nicht.
Ich meine, man kann sich an diesem Dialog mal verklicken und dann muss man eine halbe Stunde warten.
Passt wieder
zu dem Punkt, gewollt und nicht gekonnt.
So, was gibt es denn Schönes hier?
Äh, ja.
Eine rare Sten habe ich gekriegt.
Keine rare
Parrot, sondern eine rare Sten.
Mastery Challenge.
Prophecy Challenge. Epic.
Epic.
Ja.
Muss man ja auch mal sagen, ja.
Also ich finde, es ist schon ein
enormer Auf... Also von dem
Rare Iron Side
zu dem Epic Side.
Ja, es ist schon... Also...
Meine Güte.
Meine Güte. Also das ist schon...
Das ist schon ein krasser Unterschied,
oder? Also ich finde, man erkennt direkt,
dass das hier das Epic Side ist und das
hier das Rare Side.
Wie hängengeblieben ist das eigentlich?
So.
MP40 Unlock.
Oh.
Mir fällt gerade ein...
Mir fällt gerade ein,
wenn man die... Oh, nee.
Man muss ja jetzt erstmal...
Es reicht ja nicht, dass man
die Klasse leveln muss, um die Waffe
zu bekommen. Man muss jetzt ja auch quasi
noch die Waffe aufleveln, um die Upgrades
für die Waffe zu kriegen.
Oh, hab ich da gar nicht mal dran gedacht.
Was gibt's denn da so
für die MP40?
Ich mein, die Kombination, ja, von
Level Unlock
und dann nochmal
Waffen Unlock. Ich mein, ey.
Übertreib's halt.
Übrigens.
Diese Geschichte mit, es wird kein DLC geben.
Ich hab da meine eigene Theorie
zu.
Also es soll ja angeblich keine DLCs geben, sondern
zusätzliches
Features. Immer so.
Das Spiel hat auch nur
8 Karten bei Release, anstatt... Nee, Moment.
Ja, ne? 8 Karten.
Anstatt wie Battlefield 3
beispielsweise 9 plus 4.
13 Karten. Ich glaube,
die Taktik besteht darin,
dass man
dadurch, dass man jetzt keine DLCs
kaufen will, dass man weiß,
die Leute
spielen nicht dauerhaft
und dass man quasi
immer wieder zwischendurch
die Leute mit kostenlosen
Mini-DLCs
zurück ins Spiel locken möchte
und passend dazu
auch neue Cosmetics
veröffentlicht. Also immer passend
zu einem Mini-DLC
wird man passende Cosmetics, Animationen,
Voice Lines, was auch immer es geben wird,
veröffentlichen.
So dass man quasi
die Leute mit kostenlosen DLCs,
die schon keinen Bock mehr auf das Game hatten,
wieder in das Game lockt, in der Hoffnung
dadurch quasi
Sachen zu verkaufen. Also quasi
einen... Kein DLC,
sondern einen...
Eigentlich so ein Trick, um
die Leute... Um wahrscheinlich noch mehr
Kohle abzugreifen.
Konnte man mir folgen,
ja? Hoffe ich.
So, wir spielen jetzt auch mal eine Runde auf der Map, die ich kenne.
Oder mal ganz kurz, mp40.
Mal gucken. Weil mp40 war übertrieben
geil in der Alpha.
Moin, Schlomo-Schädel.
Das Evo, ja, kommt auch noch dabei.
Ah, ich muss mal Chat lesen.
Fällt mir gerade auf.
Hey Max, wirst du in naher Zukunft nochmal
eine PC-Zusammenstellung machen? Ähm,
weiß ich noch nicht. Aber es gibt ja
viele. Du kannst dir Hardware Rad zum Beispiel angucken
auf YouTube. Der macht das ganz gut.
Ich bin wieder im Sucker Squad.
Ich do doch something.
Pfff.
Ein Cyborg hat mich geownt. Ähm...
Ne, also wahrscheinlich mache ich in nächster Zeit
kein PC-Zusammenstellungs-Video
mehr.
Am Anfang des
Streams hast du was vom neuen NAS erzählt.
Was sind so die Specs? Das ist ein Singleboard
Compu... Also so...
So ein kleiner... So ein Sock. Wie heißt
es? System on Chip?
System on Chip, ähm...
Mit SATA-Anschluss.
Kann ich...
Ich kann's... Also wenn ihr das neue NAS mal sehen wollt,
kann ich's euch gleich zeigen.
Nach der Runde. Nach MP40.
Danach
muss ich auch Chat lesen.
Ich bin jetzt ein bisschen hinten dran
mit Chat. Ich merk mir jetzt wo ich war und scroll danach
nur noch hoch. Dass ich mal irgendwie
nachkomme. Moment,
muss man die auf Singleschuss vielleicht stellen?
Geht nicht, ne?
Halt still, das haben wir gleich.
Oh, ich krieg den Arsch geschossen.
Ich will nicht da drüber springen.
Ich bin bei dir, ja.
Ich retz dich.
Okay, willst nicht.
Da rennt irgendwas an mir vorbei.
Ah, shit.
STG44 Singleschuss, Leute.
Beste Waffe in dem ganzen Game.
Ähm, welcher Battlefield-Teil
ist zurzeit eigentlich am besten Einsteiger
verpflichtend? Ich würd immer den aktuellsten
spielen.
Wenn man einsteigt, würd ich immer den aktuellsten spielen.
Hallo? Spawn?
Der ist nicht under fire!
Game, erzähl keinen Scheiß!
Okay.
Ähm, ja.
Ich zeig euch das Nass mal.
Hast du schon mal Freenas
benutzt? Ja, hab ich.
Ah ja, Medpack muss man länger gedrückt haben.
Okay, die Luft ist raus für heute, Leute.
Zu viel.
Zu viel Battlefield auf einmal.
Aber ich muss euch sagen, also die 70-Kill-Runde
war echt nass.
Okay, Moment.
Nass.
Also.
Ach, der Eax ist da.
Nice.
Moin. Ne, 3. Runde.
Drei Stunden nur. Drei Stunden, nicht vier Stunden. Drei Stunden.
Warum hängt denn das jetzt?
Ah, weil die Festplatte erstmal wieder anfahren muss.
Okay, also
als Nass hab ich mir folgendes gekauft.
Ähm, also.
Ich muss sagen, ich hab mir das nicht als Nass gekauft.
Ich wollte mal damit ein bisschen rumprobieren.
Ihr wisst ja, ich hab hier ne
4AE-Kiste stehen mit 10 Gigabit
ähm
Netzwerk und 10 Gigabit Switch.
Also das kann ich damit nicht ausnutzen.
Aber an sich find ich das ne coole
coole Hardware.
Und zwar ein
so ein Teil hier hab ich mir geholt.
Also das ist beste
Hardware für Selbstbau.
Nass, wenn man nicht viele Platten braucht.
Das ist im Endeffekt
quasi nen
Passiv-Kühler, wo man hier hinten ne
Festplatte reinmachen kann und sich dann auch nen
kann sich auch nen Gehäuse noch holen.
Und
das hier vorne ist halt quasi nen kompletter
Single
Chip-Computer.
Hier vorne kommt ne Micro-SD-Karte rein.
Und hier hat man dann Gigabit
Gigabit LAN dran.
Man hat auch nen USB-2, hier kommt da Strom dran.
Und
das ist halt relativ kostenlos.
Also es ist die beste Variante, wenn man
einfach nur ne Festplatte quasi
mit Gigabit ans
ans Netzwerk stöpseln möchte.
Und ich will bei mir ja eh wieder
ein bisschen zurückbauen, weil aktuell hab ich
ja diese
Ihr kennt's wahrscheinlich.
Ich zeig's nochmal, so sieht's ja bei mir aktuell aus.
Server-Technisch.
Also
Mittlerweile ist der
Access-Point nicht mehr da.
Das ist ja das Track hier hinten im Serverraum.
Mittlerweile ist ein bisschen mehr drumherum noch.
4AE-Kiste.
Gigabit-Switch.
USB.
Paar Strom-Dinger.
Noch ein kleiner TP-Link-Switch.
Man sieht's ja hier im Prinzip besser.
Ja, also das ist die
fette Kiste hier
mit vorn jeweils 13TB-Platten
drin. Also 3x10, nicht
13TB, 3x10.
Ja, das ist ja das
wie's bei mir aktuell aussieht.
Nochmal der
Hier sieht man nochmal den
Switch, den 10G-Switch.
Genau. Und ne,
Stromverbrauch ist gar nicht so hoch.
Also das komplette Rack
alles zusammen.
Fritz-Box, Unity-Media-Box,
Switch,
USB-Server,
Verbrauch eidel.
Weil eidel, wenn die Festplatten auch runtergefahren
sind, 85 Watt.
Mit, ähm, also das ist wirklich
für so ein Ding ist das ziemlich wenig.
Mit den Festplatten
an so um die 100.
Und wenn natürlich ordentlich, dann lastet es auch noch mehr.
Aber es ist mir trotzdem zu viel und ich hab's jetzt,
wie gesagt, ich hab's jetzt ja
2 Jahre oder so in Betrieb gehabt.
Und es ist schon nice,
wenn man quasi 10G daheim hat.
Es ist schon nice, wenn man hier auch ordentlich Rechenpower
hat, wo man alles und wo man ein bisschen rumspielen kann und so.
Aber alles in allem
muss ich sagen, es ist halt doch massiv
Oversized für mich.
Deswegen werde ich jetzt umsteigen auf
ähm,
so ein Ding als NAS
und, ähm,
nen 4-Kern-Celeron-Board
für
mit TV-Karte drin,
für Fernsehaufnahmen, Nextcloud
und Zeug.
Ich brauch, ich brauch leider
2 getrennte Geräte, weil
die Kiste hier mit Nextcloud, sorry,
Nextcloud kommt hier noch mit drauf.
Das steht halt bei mir intern im Laden drinne und, ähm,
die 4-Kern-Celeron-Kiste mit
mit TV-Karte und Heimautomatisierungs-Zeug
drauf, kommt halt getrennt
ins WLAN rein. Das sind 2 komplett
unterschiedliche Stecker, also das
will ich nicht verbinden.
Ja. Und das probier ich grad aus.
Da hab ich heut drauf aufgenommen, also sprich die Kiste hier.
Ähm, ich hab zurzeit,
wir können uns ja mal drauf einloggen,
zurzeit hab ich hier Open Media Wall
drauflaufen. Das ist jetzt die Kiste
hier. Und hier
hab ich irgendwo auch meinen,
meinen Recording-Share eingerichtet da,
der hier.
Und man sieht, es ist relativ schnell.
Ähm,
also der macht die Gigabit voll.
Der macht, der macht Gigabit voll.
Wir können, wir können mal kopieren.
Wenn ich, ich hab hier nichts Großes drauf.
Wir können uns mal,
wir kopieren einfach mal was runter.
Wohlgemerkt, das ist, das ist ein
eine 40, eine 40 Euro
Kiste, ja.
Brauch ein bisschen, ok lesen ist anscheinend ein bisschen langsamer.
Aber, sag mal so,
ähm, wenn ich da jetzt vielleicht mal das,
wenn ich das Ding nochmal update,
weil mit der neuen offiziellen Distribution
ist es noch ein bisschen schneller. Also im Durchschnitt
hat er so um die 100,
um die 100 MB die Sekunde,
also Gigabit ist so ungefähr voll.
Da kannst du dich echt nicht beschweren für 40 Euro.
Und die Festplatte ist auch so eine billige
2 TB WD Green, hast du nicht gesehen.
Also das ist wirklich in Ordnung.
Für den Preis.
Und das hat, das hat
verhältnismäßig viel Rechenpower für so ein kleines,
für so ein kleines Ding.
Also es ist wirklich nicht übel das Teil.
Ja, und als Ersatz für Heim, für
als Heimatomatisierungskiste
und ähm
Mediaserver hab ich jetzt dann
nen, nen S-Rock
ich glaub das da
geholt.
Das ist so ein, so ein passiv gekühltes, genau.
So ein passiv gekühltes ITX
Celeron Board mit nem
USB Express Steckplatz.
Wunderbar, so und das braucht dann natürlich alles zusammen
deutlich weniger.
Also da bin ich dann wahrscheinlich bei, keine Ahnung
20, 25 Watt Idle.
Das ist natürlich dann auch schon ganz gut.
Ja.
Wofür braucht man so ein Teil ja, wenn man beispielsweise
sich ein eigenes NAS bauen will.
Weil aktuell läuft's, wie gesagt
aktuell läuft ja mein, mein NAS auf dieser 4 AE
Kiste hier.
Oben mit, der hier macht grad alles.
Der hier macht Internetrouter, VPN Zugang,
Nextcloud, Mediaserver,
TV-Server, NAS,
äh, Virtualisierungsgedöns,
äh, äh, äh,
viel Zeugs.
Ja, alles was ich, alles was ich brauch mal aktuell
die 4 AE Kiste. Und die langweilt sich
halt dabei, ne. Das ist der vollkommen egal.
Das ist nen 8 Kern, 8 Kern
Xeon drin, das ist das, der
dreht Däumchen dabei. Bei dem was ich
da mache. Oh, die Curly Musik
ist fertig.
Und ich wollte das heute einfach mal ausprobieren, ob man
da drauf gut Aufnahmen speichern
kann, weil man, wenn man
mit Shadowplay aufnimmt, der
buffert ja lokal erstmal bei mir hier
auf dem Rechner auf die SSD und dann
schiebt er beim Speichern übers Netzwerk.
Und das
muss man ja sagen.
Funktioniert ja prinzipiell ganz gut.
Hier sind die Aufnahmen
von heut. Und ich hoffe die 70 Kill
Runde ist dabei. Also wie gesagt
ich werd, ich werd downgraden.
Von meiner fetten HP. Achso ja und
haha. Kann ich euch auch noch zeigen.
Wie gesagt
aktuell läuft ja alles. Hallo?
Darf ich mal zoomen? So.
Aktuell läuft ja wie gesagt auch
Internetzugang und so hier drüber. Da ist
ne 4 Port
Internetzwerkkarte drinne.
Da ist ne 2 10G
Onboard Netzwerkkarten drinne. Management Interface.
Also Netzwerk hat da genug.
So und
das ist halt auch eine Sache, warum ich jetzt
warum ich
jetzt das ein bisschen downgraden will.
Es ist halt eine Kiste. So sollte man wirklich die
eine Kiste abkacken.
Geht halt nichts mehr. Da geht mein Internet nicht mehr.
Also klar ich kann mich immer noch an die Fritzbox
stöpseln ja. Da geht mein Internetzugang nicht.
Dann ist mein, ist das ganze
Aufnahmen weg. Media Zeug funktioniert nicht
mehr. Nextcloud geht nicht mehr.
Na das ist halt, das ist halt ein bisschen doof.
Es ist recht unwahrscheinlich, dass das Ding den Abgang
macht ja. Zumal das auch komplett
rumeigelt. Rumeigelt?
Wie machst du das mit den Backups? Oh da kann ich gleich was
zu erzählen. Das ist ganz interessant.
Ähm ja und jetzt splitt ich das
halt auf. Also quasi ich hab ne
Mikrotik Router gekauft für
ja Routing Internetzugang.
Diese Celeron Kiste für
für ähm
Mediaserver und für Heimautomatisierung
und halt hier diesen
kleinen Otroid für Nextcloud und
halt NAS. Da kommt dann ne 10TB
Platte dran. Ähm
und nochmal ne 10TB Platte an USB
auf die nachts gesynct wird.
Ganz, ganz klassisch, ganz billig.
Ja genau das kann man
also CrispyTV das
geht natürlich auch ja. Wenn man, wenn man
so ne Synology oder irgendwie ein QNAP
oder irgendwie so ein. Wie heißen die?
Synology? Wie heißen denn
die anderen? Äh doch QNAP
genau. QNAP sag ich doch.
Ähm da kann man natürlich auch wunderbar mitmachen.
So ähm ja
zum Thema Updates kann ich
auch noch was zeigen.
Ich mach das
folgendermaßen. Ich benutze das
hier als Backup Tool. Ich mein ich hab das auf dem
Account jetzt nicht eingerichtet. Ich kann euch das jetzt nicht
in Aktion zeigen.
Ich benutze das hier als Backup Tool, das
ist ein, ist ein Open Source
Open Source Backup
Programm. Ist auch relativ beliebt, wie man ja sieht.
Wird maintained, also quasi
ist aktiv, kriegt laufend Updates.
Hat 4000 Sterne auf GitHub, ist also ziemlich
ziemlich beliebt. Ist halt ein Kommandozeilen
Tool, ja. Ähm
geht unter Windows, geht unter Linux
geht glaub ich sogar unter Mac.
Und damit mach ich
Updates von meinem
System auf das NAS.
Man kann's
auch umgedreht machen. Man kann auch das quasi das
NAS Updates machen lassen von
den Systemen.
Das geht auch über SSH.
Also man muss da nicht von außen nach innen zugreifen
können. Ähm
Dann werd
ich einmal, also ich mein
die Backups kommen da dann drauf. Dann werd ich einmal
die Backups extern spiegeln auf ne zweite
Platte, die hier in USB hängt. Mach ich
halt nachts irgendwie noch ein AirSync oder sowas.
Ja und wenn man dann die
Updates, wenn man dann die Updates
noch zum Beispiel auf
ähm Google
Drive, Amazon Drive, sonst was hochladen
möchte, kann ich eigentlich nur
das hierfür empfehlen, weil die unterstützen so
ziemlich alles was geht
als Backendsystem.
Also sprich man kann dann sein komplettes
Backup Archive
was man mit Borg gemacht hat, kann man dann
zum Beispiel spiegeln lassen
verschlüsselt auf ähm
Amazon Drive oder auf
auf alles im Endeffekt, ja.
Und das ist ne ganz coole Kombination.
So läuft das mit Backup.
Wie zeigt man denn sowas ein, Raspberry Pi?
Ja der Raspberry Pi äh hat halt den Vorteil
du
findest Tutorials für alles, du findest
Hardware für alles.
Es ist die beste Plattform, wenn man mit so ein bisschen was
kleinem anfangen will. Der Raspberry Pi
an sich ist keine, es ist
Architektur-technisch
keine schöne Plattform, aber
der ist
quasi komplett
gepatcht. Er geht alles
drauf.
Also zum Einstieg ist es schon am besten, wobei
man halt sagen muss, der Raspberry
eignet sich für ein paar Sachen nicht.
Unter anderem, als NAS
ist ein Raspberry Pi Kacke.
Dem Raspberry Pi fehlt ne SATA
Schnittstelle, dem Res- oder aber ne USB 3
Schnittstelle mit, die ordentlich angebunden
ist, sowie
nen ordentlich angebundenen Gigabit
Port. Also NAS und
die CPU ist auch nicht die schnellste, vor allem wenn du
die Platte noch verschlüsseln willst.
Ne, weil, Werde, da geht's
nicht drum, wie die Arm-CPUs auf
dem Raspberry laufen ist das Problem.
Das ist ja quasi nur
ne drittklassige Arm-Plattform.
Das ist ja hauptsächlich irgendein
proprietäres Broadcom-Gedöns, der Raspberry.
Mit Armkern letztendlich.
Also hast du Cloud-Backups.
Ich, nur nen kleiner Teil.
Ich backupe
also ich backupe
nur, also
sagen wir mal so, auf
auf das System hier.
Auf Manas backupe ich mehr oder weniger
mein komplettes
Heimatverzeichnis, ja. Also in dem Fall hier
halt C Doppelpunkt User
Username wird dahin gebackupt.
Und es wird auch einmalig gespiegelt
nachts auf die zweite
Platte, die hier dranhängt dann.
Aktuell ist es halt alles auf der 4AE
Kiste. Alles auf der Kiste.
Und ein kleiner Teil davon, das was
wirklich wichtig ist, das sind
plus 2-3 Gigabyte, das ist nicht so extrem
viel, ja. Die anderen Backups sind
halt ne ganze Ecke größer.
Aber die Sachen, die wirklich wichtig sind,
die
ähm, spiegel ich dann auch mit
Airclone auf Cloud.
Auf die Cloud hier.
Oh, wie heißen die?
Backblaze war es, genau.
Auf die hier. Da hab ich nen
Was ist denn?
Die haben ein ganz gutes Angebot, die sind relativ günstig.
Was Speicherplatz
kostet.
Oh, der Master Clover kommt morgen nach Frankfurt.
Hab ich ja ganz vergessen.
Ähm
Tja, wo haben die jetzt Pricing stehen?
Es ist nicht so
Wie machst du deine Backups
für die Handys?
Gar nicht. Ab und zu mal,
wenn's mir danach ist.
Das ist nicht das, was ich hab.
Das ist was anderes.
Das hier. Ja, das sieht besser aus.
Pricing. Was kostet's denn
jetzt?
Ich hasse so Seiten. Das ist nicht viel.
Das hat irgendwie 4 Dollar oder so kostet das, was ich hab.
Ähm. Wo sieht man denn jetzt was
der Scheiß kostet?
Ist es doch. Genau, also das ist wirklich
ziemlich günstig.
Kann man sich ja ausrechnen.
Das kostet
0,005 Euro.
Also 0,5 Cent
pro Gigabyte.
Also bezahlste
im Endeffekt
für einen Terabyte
bezahlste 5
Das kommt mir ein bisschen teuer vor.
Also ich bilde
mir eigentlich bezahlt bloß irgendwie um die
um die 4
4 4
beziehungsweise in den SFP-Port
weglässt, hast du halt nur 5
und
ordentliche Hardware
drin, POE, wenn man
braucht für eine Kamera oder so
und dann habe ich schön aufgesplittet
dann habe ich 3 Geräte und
ähm, es ist nicht mehr
so Single Point of Failure mäßig und viel
viel viel Strom sparender
als vorher, so
sieht es aus
hast du eigentlich eine statische IP daheim?
nein, keine statische IP
aber relativ statisch
weil die halt
nicht oft vergeben wird, aber nicht so statisch
dass man sich drauf verlassen kann
das macht aber auch nichts, weil man kann sich einfach
einen Dünn-DNS einrichten
entweder
macht man das selbst, auf einem System
was man irgendwo gemietet hat mit
oder ich persönlich
finde den hier am besten
den da, sieht zwar
ein bisschen gewöhnungsbedürftig
sein, aber ich finde das ist der beste Dünn-DNS-Provider
hat eine API, die kannst du
dynamisch updaten und das ist schon ganz schick
also ich finde das ist der beste
Dünn-DNS-Provider
hast du schon mal
mit Proxmox
und VMware vSphere gearbeitet
was würdest du vorziehen?
naja, in Business-Umgebungen
würde ich eindeutig VMware nehmen
also da wo auch ein bisschen Geld
dahinter ist, ja
da würde ich eindeutig VMware nehmen
ich finde VMware
prinzipiell die beste Virtualisierungslösung
ich finde VMware prinzipiell die beste Virtualisierungslösung
also vor allem auch das Gesamtpaket
VMware macht komische Dinger
die haben es jetzt erst geschafft ein ordentliches
HTML5 Frontend
rauszubringen, weil sie haben ihre alten Clients
eingestampft und danach kam so ein komisches Flash
Frontend, ich mein Flash Frontend
wir sind im Jahr 2018
und jetzt haben sie es ja geschafft ein HTML5
Frontend zu machen
privat verwende ich ja auch halt
für VMs KVM
also wenn es auf Linux ist KVM oder halt
vor allem Workstation auf Windows
aber ähm...
wenn es nicht umsonst
sein muss, beziehungsweise wenn man nicht
nur Linux
Virtualisieren will
dann VMware
vor allem im Profibereich
daheim Proxmox und vor allem
wenn man quasi nur Linux Virtualisieren
will auf jeden Fall, das ist auch nicht schlecht
das Frontend ist besser
als von VMware
okay das neue HTML5 Frontend geht auch
bin gerade mitten in
meiner Ausbildung zum Physi und daher
mal die Frage aller Fragen, hast du Zertifikate
nein hab ich nicht
ich hab mal vor Jahren mit Cisco
das allerkleinste
Cisco Zeit, also ewig her
ich sag jetzt mal vor 15 Jahren
oder so
na nicht ganz
oder
das war als ich noch in Offenbach in die Schule gegangen bin
das ist noch länger her
das ist noch viel länger her
20 Jahre
warte mal, nee nicht ganz
warte mal, jetzt ist 2018
15 Jahre, ja doch 15 Jahre
kommt gut hin
hab ich mal ein CCNA gemacht
aber das ist schon
das ist ja schon antik
ansonsten hab ich keine Zertifikate
nein, und es ist so wie
weil wer das sagt, man muss es nicht übertreiben
also
es ist allemal vorzuziehen
du kannst die Leute überzeugen
mit dass du was kannst anstatt
mit Zertifikate zu redeln
wenn du natürlich krasser mehr Schein als Sein
verhaltend werden möchtest
was nicht alle sind wohlgemerkt
auch wenn sich das jetzt vielleicht so angehört hat
dann sind Zertifikate natürlich nicht verkehrt
dann gibts
easy money
wenn du die Leute noch ein bisschen beschwätzen kannst
leider sind die meisten mehr Schein als Sein
Consultants
der Name suggeriert zwar so nach dem Motto
man konsultiert diejenigen dann dazu
wenn man es selbst nicht besser weiß
aber in der Regel möchte man eigentlich
einfach nur so ein bisschen Verantwortung dahin schieben
so nach dem Motto, dann bin ich nicht mehr dran schuld, wenn die es verkacken
was ist das eigentlich?
Backup System, ok, werde ich mal geupdatet
tja
so ist es leider
also vor allem im IT Bereich
gibts sehr viel
Schein als Sein, also sehr viele Leute
wurde
die dir halt die ersten 10 Minuten
versuchen zu erzählen, dass sie die geilsten sind
und du denen das vielleicht noch kurz glaubst
aber dann relativ schnell feststellst
da ist überhaupt nichts dahinter
das klappt halt auch oftmals nur auf einer gewissen Ebene
wenn man da halt als jemand dabei sitzt
und seine Technik auskennt, merkt man relativ schnell
dass da eigentlich einfach nur geschwallt wird
deswegen halte ich es auch für wichtig
dass in einer
Firma die sich Sachen kaufen will
kaufen möchte, anschaffen möchte
oder Projekte umsetzen lassen möchte
von irgendwelchen Consultants
oder irgendwelche Software holen will
dass da von Anfang an Leute
dabei sind
die erstens am Ende die Software verwenden müssen
und zweitens sich mit der Materie auskennen
weil sonst kannst du da viel erzählen
wenn der Tag lang ist
und das wird dann auch gekauft
wohl einmal lehren, wenn ich sonst nichts zu tun habe
oh da war aber ganz schön viel drin
haja
so jetzt muss ich mal den Masterclub ausschreiben
ähm
eine Frage habe ich noch
wie gestaltest du dein Smartphone
alles über eine Plattform
ne
achso
ich habe mich verlesen, ich habe Smartphone gelesen
Smart Home
ja ich mache das über
ne ich habe unterschiedliche Dinge, ich mache das hier mit
damit mache ich meine
Heimatomatisierung
die Homepage sieht ziemlich
kacke aus
aber die haben halt Komponenten für sie ziemlich alles
und wenn nicht
lässt sich super einfach selber was machen
wirklich ultra simpel
weil du auch einfach
MQTT Sachen einbinden kannst
du kannst quasi Sensor mit Curl hinschicken
und sowas
ähm das ist toll
HomeAssist ist die beste Plattform für Heimatomatisierung
wenn man selbst ein bisschen was bauen kann
es ist halt auch viel selbst gebastelt
weil für manche Sachen gab es nichts
zum Beispiel ich habe eine Heizung von diesem Hersteller hier
im Keller
und die Heizung ist gut da kann ich nichts dagegen sagen
aber die haben vorne
ich versuche mal ob man das sieht
ich versuche euch das mal zu zeigen
warte mal
das ist total wir
da sieht man es schön
die Heizung hat hier vorne so ein Schaltfeld
und da oben sind zwei LEDs
also der hat jetzt da schon was drauf gesetzt
und dort kann man quasi
sowas hier andocken
und da drüber Dinger auslesen
und sowas habe ich mir halt gekauft
so einen offiziellen
so ist so ein Kabel da
das kommt dann da vorne rein
in diesen Heizungsausleser
und das ist dann an einem Raspberry
Zero W
im Keller
der macht auch noch ein bisschen mehr
der macht noch Luftfeuchtigkeit
und Temperatur
und sowas
und soll in Zukunft auch mal
Strom messen
nennt man das mit so Klemmen
kann man das machen
so
und da habe ich halt selbst was gebastelt
das Geschwubbel
was die Heizung quasi über diesen
optischen Link ausgibt
auszulesen
und dann hier in Home Assistant rein zu pushen
es ist halt einfach mit der Software
deswegen ist es echt gut
Evoli ist echt
es ist wirklich so
oftmals haben die besten Projekte
eine scheiß Homepage
das ist witzig
es gibt in diesem Bereich richtig viele
hässliche Homepages
selbst bauen bei Heimautomatisierung
ist traurigerweise immer noch sicherer
als fertig zu kaufen
ja leider ist das so
ich würde keiner fertigen Lösung
für meine Heimautomatisierung trauen
keiner
habt ihr es gelesen auf Twitter
mit der Kamera
ich habe mir eine Kamera geholt
und ich verrate jetzt nicht
wie es geht
der Hersteller hat mich gefragt
es erstmal nicht zu verraten
ich habe mir eine Kamera gekauft
und
man kann
also
es ist jetzt nicht komplett
trivial
also ein bisschen Ahnung von dem was man macht
muss man schon haben
aber man kann sehr einfach
das Admin Passwort von der Kamera auslesen
ohne das Admin Passwort
zu wissen
also sprich
entweder sind Gäste im Wlan
können sie sich ganz einfach Zugriff
auf die Kamera verschaffen
oder aber
es gibt Leute die haben vielleicht
das quasi Port weiterleitet aus dem Internet
auf die Kamera
und da kann dann quasi Gott und die Welt
die Kamera aus dem Internet
wenn sie nicht aufgepasst haben
sich das Admin Passwort besorgen
und hat dann direkt Zugriff auf das Web Interface
kann dann quasi die komplette Wohnung ausspionieren
kann das Mikrofon abhören Aufnahmen von der SD Karte auslesen
ja das habe ich innerhalb von 2 Stunden
quasi nach Anschalten
der Kamera rausgekriegt dass das möglich ist
und daran sieht man
halt mal wieder diese ganzen Dinger die so als Security
Sachen
beworben werden
sind oftmals
unglaublich unsicher
wegen OpenSense weißt du wie ich im LAN
IPv6 Adressen verteilen kann
wegen meinem DSLite Anschluss
kann ich nämlich nur noch Sachen über IPv6
fragen
gar nicht du musst keine IPv6 Adressen
verteilen
das ist ja das schöne an IPv6
du musst einfach nur IPv6 einschalten
dann hast du zumindest schon mal eine Local Adresse
für IPv6
und wenn du eine
also wenn du fest vergeben
möchtest
oder umgekehrt wenn du von deinem Provider
quasi ein Netz gekriegt hast
ich weiß nicht
wie das bei Unity Media aussieht
was man da für größere Netze
wie viele Netze man kriegt
dann stellst du das entweder bei deinen
Geräten von Hand ein
die Adresse oder machst DHCPv6
wobei ich das noch nie
gemacht habe ehrlich gesagt
ja und wenn du mit den Geräten direkt ins Internet willst
oder von außen nach innen dann brauchst du natürlich eine öffentlich geroutete
Adresse
das heißt irgendwie sowas wirst du machen müssen
aber du kannst bestimmt
IPv6 DHCP machen mit OpenSense
ist wahrscheinlich kein Ding
und ich bin mir noch nicht mal sicher ob man das braucht
ehrlich gesagt vielleicht geht es doch einfach so
IPv6 ist ziemlich gut
was so Autodiscovery
und Router Announcements
und sowas angeht oftmals muss man da gar nichts selbst machen
ja Eax das ist auch gar nicht mal so schlecht
ne Kameras abkleben
Mikrofon abstöpseln
ich mein wie gesagt
Admin
bzw. Routepasswort war von der Kamera
wenn man den passenden Befehl hat
zum Auslesen dauert das
eine halbe Sekunde und man hat Routzugriff auf die Kamera
das ist halt der komplette Witz gewesen
die ganzen Heimautomatisierungssysteme
bzw. auch das was so als
Security Alarm
und sowas verkauft wird
das ist alles so übertrieben unsicher
das würde ich mir auf keinen Fall einbauen
selbst machen ist die beste Variante
in dem Fall
und man muss sich ja auch mal überlegen
man sollte
also wenn man Heimautomatisierung
betreibt sollte man mit den Dingern anfangen
die einem wirklich einen gewissen
Mehrwert bringen
natürlich unabhängig davon
also ist halt abhängig davon was man will
ja für die einen Leute ist es schon
eine super Erleichterung wenn man sich quasi
einen Ausschalter macht ins Schlafzimmer
kann man zum Beispiel mit einem Amazon Dash Button
machen
wo man drauf drückt und
es wird quasi im kompletten Haus ausgeschaltet
die Heizung runtergefahren und sowas
das sind so Sachen muss man sich halt überlegen was man will
und damit sollte man anfangen und ich wette mit euch
eines der Sachen
die am unsinnigsten ist
und am wenigsten bringt für die meisten Leute
sind
intelligente Türschlösser
das hat kaum Mehrwert
es
erspart einem kaum Zeit
und es macht
das ganze Ding brutal unsicher
wenn das Ding einen Fehler hat
also intelligente Türschlösser ist eigentlich totaler
Fail total bescheuert
alles andere
warum nicht ja halt wenn es einem was bringt
ja oder
beispielsweise wenn man sagt ja ich möchte jetzt hier
Auswertung von meinem Stromverbrauch machen
oder sowas ja das ist ja auch gut
aber das einzige was mir jetzt beispielsweise
bei
so intelligenten Türschlössern einfällt
und wo man sagen könnte ja okay was man
als Mehrwert
irgendwie bezeichnen könnte ist
so nach dem Motto ja du kannst jetzt irgendwie
Freunde reinlassen wenn du nicht da bist aber
will man das
also mir fällt keine Situation
ein wo mal jemand bei mir
geklingelt hat und ich nicht da war und ich gesagt
oh ich lass dich mal kurz rein also
oder
hattet ihr die Situation schon mal
also fällt mir jetzt nichts ein
ich finde intelligente Türschlösser haben
keinen wirklichen Mehrwert und machen
die ganze Sache nur brutal unsicher
und es ist ja nicht so dass die noch keine
Sicherheitsprobleme gehabt hätten wenn man sich überlegt
ja dann die meisten Hersteller
haben ja irgendwie ihre eigene Cloud Lösung
dabei das heißt du hast dann erstmal ein intelligentes Türschloss
was sich mal zum Hersteller nach außen verbindet
total Fail generell
ist es eine der größten Probleme
bei diesen ganzen fertigen Heimautomaten
automatisierungslösungen
dass die nicht
dafür gedacht sind sie
lokal zu betreiben so wie es sein sollte
eine Heimautomatisierungslösung
hat standardmäßig
es sei denn man möchte das und schaltet
es explizit frei nichts
im Internet verloren sowohl von innen
nach außen nicht und schon mal gar nicht von außen nach innen
standardmäßig sollte das
komplett lokal laufen unabhängig von
irgendeinem Hersteller oder sonst was
das ist
Heimautomatisierung das ist nicht
Cloud Automatisierung oder
Remote Automatisierung
das ist Heimautomatisierung das sollte erstmal alles
komplett lokal sein und das ist es
bei den meisten Herstellern eben nicht
und das ist halt schon mal kompletter Fail
weil will ich wirklich wenn man
zum Beispiel
was saubeliebt ist im
Heimautomatisierungsbereich
sind diese Xiaomi
Produkte hier
Xiaomi Dinger
weil die sind halt billig
kostet im Endeffekt nix
ja
kaufst bei AliExpress oder Gearbest
oder so kostet ein Türsensor
7,80 Euro und die gibt es teilweise noch billiger
ähm
da kannst du dir im Endeffekt schon mit
150 Euro quasi
die wichtigsten
Sachen mit Türsensor versorgen
mit ähm
was haben die standardmäßig noch drinne
im Programm
was waren das Türsensor ich glaub ich glaub Lampen
also du kannst quasi für 150 Euro mehr oder weniger
schau mal grundlegend dein Haus
versorgen
mit Sensoren ja mit dem Zeug das Problem ist
das läuft über alles über ne
Cloud in China irgendwo
und da muss man sich halt fragen will man das
wirklich haben
übrigens für so billig Zeug AliExpress
beste Seite
guck mal das scheiß kostet hä
ja das ist okay das ist ein Suchbegriff
hast du immer
Firefox da als Will
ja was Firefox was möchtest
du mir sagen dass die Suche nicht
gebürstelt ist oder was
das geht halt alles über ne China Cloud
ja Temperatursensor Luftdrucksensor
Luftfeuchtigkeitssensor genau so ein Scheiß
Alarm
ähm
aber es geht halt über ne Cloud in China
es ist halt billig es ist das billigste
was es gibt die Dinger sind auch gar nicht so schlecht
aber es geht halt über ne Cloud in China
das ist halt für den Arsch
oh das ist gut
das ist entspannt das muss ich mir speichern
also was ich aktuell habe als Türsensor
ist
ähm
auch von AliExpress
und zwar einfach nur
weil es so unglaublich billig ist
diesen Krempel aus China zu bestellen
ähm die Dinger habe ich aktuell
und halt die würde ich auch nur
bei ner Aktion kaufen
davon habe ich jetzt insgesamt
ich glaube 14 Stück
16 Stück
irgendwie so in dem Dreh
die habe ich mir immer bei ner Aktion gekauft
wo es jeweils nur ein bisschen
mehr als 10 Dollar das Stück gekostet hat
das ist halt richtig günstig
und die kannst du ohne Probleme an
ein Home Assistant anbinden
dann weißt du immer wann Fenster auf sind
wann Türen offen sind
und kannst dementsprechend drauf reagieren
also kannst du zum Beispiel sagen
ähm
wenn das Badfenster offen ist
und die Luftfeuchtigkeit
hoch
das bedeutet er hat das Fenster
aufgemacht nach dem Duschen
deswegen machen wir jetzt
die Heizung aus
das ist jetzt ein simples Beispiel
natürlich kannst du noch viel mehr machen
ähm aber du kannst halt
du musst halt erstmal die Informationen
in dein Heimatomatisierungssystem
reinbekommen
und du brauchst dann quasi
tja also
du brauchst Sensoren und du brauchst halt
Sachen die du machen kannst
und dann kannst du es halt automatisieren
du brauchst halt erstmal Sensoren
die feststellen wie das Sache ist
und dann kannst du halt darauf reagieren
wie ist die Luftfeuchtigkeit hoch
weißt du das Fenster im Bad wurde aufgemacht
sprich der Typ war gerade duschen und hat das Fenster aufgemacht
das heißt wir machen jetzt die Heizung aus
alternativ kannst du dann auch
quasi 5 Minuten später das Licht im Bad
ausschalten lassen oder so
oder du könntest sagen ok
jetzt ist es nach 22 Uhr
oder nach Sonnenuntergang
deswegen machen wir den Rollo wieder hoch
weil er hat das Badfenster aufgemacht
das ist hohe Luftfeuchtigkeit
wenn der Rollo unten ist dann geht die Luft nicht raus
solche Dinger kannst du dann halt machen
anfängt, die für einen persönlich am meisten bringen. Also das, was einen am meisten nervt,
sollte man als erstes machen, dass man da motiviert ist. Und dass man dann sieht,
dass es was bringt. Und das Schöne an Home Assistant ist halt, du kriegst halt alles,
du kriegst halt alles irgendwie rein. Man kann auch ganz abgedrehte Sachen machen. Man kann
sich zum Beispiel auch einen Gewichtssensor, einen kleinen, unter einen Bettpfosten machen
und dann legt man sich abends ins Bett und fünf Minuten später geht alles auf Nacht.
Oder solche Dinge. Gibt eigentlich keine Grenzen. Ja, du könntest, man könnte,
um es jetzt mal übertrieben zu sagen, man könnte die Beleuchtung, die am Morgen angeht,
wenn es dunkel ist, die Farbe einstellen, je nachdem, wie viel Verspätung gerade der Zug hat.
Solche Dinge. Also da sind im Prinzip keine Grenzen gesetzt. Ich könnte zum Beispiel sagen,
okay, es ist, es ist, es ist, es ist, es ist, es ist, es ist, es ist, es ist, es ist, es ist, es ist, es ist,
es ist dunkel, ich stehe auf, also sprich, der Bewegungssensor im Flur merkt, dass, bzw. meine
Tür ist offen, es ist Werktag, der Gewichtssensor im Bett ist nicht mehr da, das heißt, der Max ist
aufgestanden, will zur Arbeit und ich stelle fest, ah, der Zug hat 20 Minuten Verspätung,
dann zeigt der mir gleich mal irgendwie irgendwas. Dann zeigt der mir auf meinem Dashboard im Flur,
ich habe im Flur ein Tablet als, als heimautomatisiertes Dashboard hängen,
zeigt der mir gleich, wenn ich da dran vorbei laufe, an, Achtung, Max,
der Zug hat 20 Minuten Verspätung, okay, was, ja, kannst du, sind der Kreativität keine Grenzen
gesetzt, was du so machen kannst. Ja doch, in der Evoli, sowas hier, wie, wie ich gerade gezeigt
habe, ist zum Beispiel so ein Tür, so ein Türsensor gewesen, was, warum man ein bisschen,
bisschen Hang dazu haben sollte, die Sachen selbst zu machen, ist, weil man sehr viel Geld sparen kann
und weil die Lösungen oftmals besser sind. Zum Beispiel, ferngesteuerte Lichter ist,
ist kein Problem. Gibt's, gibt's, äh, nimmt, also, fertige RGB-LEDs, äh, also, Lampen gibt's massig,
massig. Nimmst du am besten irgendeine Z-Wave-Lampe oder, WLAN ist nicht so schön, bei Lampen geht's,
aber bei allem, was für Batterie betrieben wird, ist WLAN kacke, weil WLAN zu viel Strom verbraucht,
ähm, ja, also, zum Beispiel, was ne super Geschichte ist, wenn man sagt, okay, also, ein, also, eine,
ein Wert, den man immer braucht, wenn man, oder oftmals braucht, wenn man was automatisieren
möchte, ist zum Beispiel Temperatur, Luftfeuchtigkeit, aber hauptsächlich Temperatur.
Temperatur ist oftmals Teil von, von vielen Automatisierungen, dass man wissen möchte,
wie viel Temperatur ist es, ja. Es ist ja auch in der Küche so, wenn du quasi,
äh, in der Küche den Sensor hast und sagst, okay, hohe Temperatur, Luftfeuchtigkeit, so was,
ich glaube, der Backofen ist an, irgendwas, ja, ähm, also, Temperatur zum Beispiel, Temperatur,
Luftfeuchtigkeit, Luftdruck und sowas, das ist so, so Standard, das willst du eigentlich bei jedem
Sensor haben und das lässt sich sehr simpel, einfach, äh, selbst bauen. Du brauchst nen,
ha, wie heißt das Ding? Ist das der? Ja, so was hier zum Beispiel, genau, so einen brauchst du
und nen passendes Board.
Also man sieht auch, das ist viel zu teuer, das gibt es viel billiger.
Das gibt es im 5er-Pack für 3,20 Euro.
Und entweder schließt du das Zeug an Raspberry an, lohnt sich alle, also an einen WLAN-Raspberry, also an Raspberry Zero W.
Allerdings, ein Raspberry lohnt sich nur, wenn du noch mehr an dieser Stelle damit machen möchtest.
Ansonsten kommen wir in Bereiche, wo man sich kleinere Controller kaufen sollte.
Zum Beispiel eine ESP, sowas da.
Das sind dann ganz kleine, die kann man dann auch wireless betreiben, weil die, ähm, nicht wireless betreiben, theoretisch mit Batterie betreiben.
Aber ein Raspberry ist schon mal ein guter Anfang.
Ein Raspberry ausgestattet mit ordentlichen Sensoren und allem möglichen, kann man schon mal gut rumspielen bei.
So, ich muss mal aufs Klo.
Ich bin gleich wieder da, Leute.
Gleich wieder am Start.
So, wieder am Start.
Ein nicer Sound.
So, hab ich irgendwas übersehen?
Hey Max, hätte mal eine Frage zum Thema WLAN, ja dann frag.
Achso, hast du schon.
Achso, soll ich mal das Klo ausblenden, hä?
Ne, ist weg.
Ähm, ich hab mir vor kurzem einen Laptop gekauft und Ubuntu drauf installiert.
Mittlerweile hab ich auch einen WLAN-Treiber dafür gefunden.
Der Laptop frisst sehr viel Strom, irgendwelche Ideen.
Also, es ist schon mal blöd, dass man einen WLAN-Treiber suchen muss in der Regel.
Das Schöne bei Linux ist, entweder es geht direkt oder es geht schwierig bis gar nicht.
Hehehe.
Also zumindest was Hardware-Treiber und so angeht.
Ähm, das ist immer so ein bisschen so eine Sache.
Ähm, tja, wenn das Notebook unter Linux viel Strom verbraucht, das kommt drauf an, wie gut die ganzen Teile unterstützt werden.
Weil ich mein...
Es ist ein Unterschied, ob du quasi, ja, die Hardware zum größten Teil verwenden kannst.
Ja, also sprich, ob du aus der Grafikkarte ein bisschen Performance rauskriegst, äh, oder ob man auch noch die ganzen Energiespar-Zustände unterstützt.
Was oftmals viele Treiber eine Weile brauchen, bis sie das gut hinkriegen.
Also, es könnte durchaus sein, dass da vieles, ähm, nicht hundertprozentig unterstützt ist.
Ich mein...
Intel-CPU-Technik ist kein Problem.
Das Ding wird sich, wird sich runtertacken.
Auf jeden Fall.
Das, das klappt.
Und ansonsten kommt's halt drauf an, was sonst noch so drauf ist.
In der Regel kann man sagen, dass, ähm, wenn das nicht, wenn das nicht wirklich gut unterstützt ist, das Notebook unter Linux in der Regel ein bisschen mehr Strom verbraucht als unter Windows.
Das ist jetzt nicht doppelt so viel oder so, aber es ist mehr.
Es sei denn, es ist halt ein Gerät, was wirklich gut unterstützt wird.
Also es liegt halt einfach daran, dass viele Hersteller...
halt ihre Windows-Treiber in ganzen Krempel reinbauen und wenn nicht der Hersteller selbst den Treiber entwickelt hat für Linux, sondern andere, dass sie das mal gar nicht wissen, wie das alles geht.
Was geht hier ab?
Eigentlich bin ich fertig mit dem Stream, deswegen geht hier wenig ab noch.
Ah ja, das hast du ja bei Werde geschrieben, das kannst du natürlich auch machen.
Du kannst mal gucken.
Wobei, PowerTop, ich weiß nicht, war PowerTop irgendwie nicht, nicht duplicated oder so?
Weißt du, aber du kannst schon gucken, was, wie was verbraucht.
Ja klar, du kannst auch einfach mal ein Hardtop oder sowas machen und schauen.
Was viel verbraucht, was zum Beispiel durchaus sein kann, dass wenn du einen Browser laufen hast, dass da irgendein Tab oder irgendeine Seite ordentlich zieht.
Ich meine, heutzutage ist es ja normal, dass eigentlich der Rechner nichts macht, außer der Browser, der irgendwie 3 GB RAM verbraucht und 50 % CPU.
Dann guckt man sich das hier mal an.
Guck mal, da ist nichts auf, nichts.
Ich spiele ein bisschen Musik von YouTube.
500 MB.
Firefox, guck mal, Firefox.
Scheiß, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6 Tabs und YouTube-Video.
Gigabyte RAM.
Browser sind absolut gestört, was das angeht.
Max, was hältst du von HP-Omen-PCs?
Hatte ich noch nie.
Sind das nicht die X-förmigen Dinger?
Oder bringe ich das jetzt gerade durcheinander?
Was?
Naja, nicht wirklich X-förmig.
Da, doch hier.
Sowas da, genau.
Ja.
Doch, genau.
Weiß ich nicht.
Weil hatte ich noch nie.
Guck, im Prinzip ist es ja nicht einfach.
Also im Prinzip ist es ja relativ einfach rauszugehen, ob die Dinger was taugen.
Guck einfach, was die Dinger für Komponenten drin haben und was die Komponenten normalerweise so kosten.
Und dann weißt du, ob das was taugt.
Die können den PC auch nicht besser zusammenbauen als du.
Die können prinzipiell gucken, dass das gut harmoniert.
Aber ganz ehrlich, so diese 0815 Standard Gaming Hardware, da wirst du eigentlich kaum was finden.
Was nicht harmoniert.
Das Schlimmste, was dir passieren kann, ist, dass der RAM in deinem Mainboard nicht läuft.
Weil, was auch immer.
Das ist doch das, was am häufigsten vorkommt.
Es geht jede Grafikkarte mit jedem Mainboard.
Wenn die CPU unterstützt wird, jede CPU mit jedem Mainboard, mit jeder Grafikkarte, mit jedem RAM, meistens zumindest.
Mit einem Lüfter, wenn er passt.
Ja, jedes Gehäuse, was den passenden Formfaktor hat.
Also, eigentlich kannst du da gar nichts so sehr...
Ja, gar nicht so sehr ins Klo greifen mit Hardwarekauf, ja.
Das heißt, deswegen können die Hersteller da auch jetzt nicht so super was rausholen.
Ja, klar, die können da ein schönes Kühlkonzept bauen oder sonst was.
Aber das kannst du auch.
Dann kaufst du einfach einen ordentlichen Noctua-Lüfter oder sowas.
Und dann wird das Ding auch nicht warm.
Also, ich bin der Meinung, diese ganze Gaming-PC-Geschichte braucht kein Mensch.
Selbst bauen, wenn man das irgendwie hinkriegt oder wenn man irgendeinen kennt, der das kann,
ist auch nicht so schlecht.
Das ist auf jeden Fall die bessere Variante.
Es ist deutlich günstiger.
Es ist besser, individuell auf einen zugeschnitten, was man braucht.
Man hat auch wirklich nur das, was man braucht.
Diese Gaming-Hardware hat oftmals viel Stuss dabei, viel Blödsinn dabei, den man nicht braucht.
Bei Gaming-Notebooks sieht es natürlich anders aus.
Ja, da ist mit dem Bau nichts.
Da würde ich dann gucken.
Aber rein für Gaming-PCs würde ich mir nie sowas kaufen.
Auch kein Alienware oder sowas.
Gibt's ja, was gibt's?
Alienware gibt's, Omen gibt's.
Razer hat jetzt auch so ein Dinger.
Rocket hat auch Notebooks.
Schenker gab's früher.
Aber was gibt's?
Gibt's die eigentlich noch?
Schenker-Notebooks?
Die waren ganz cool.
Also die XMG-Dinger waren recht nice mal eine Zeit lang.
Was gibt's denn sonst noch für Gaming-PC-Hersteller?
Das ist alles nicht so toll.
Was ist eigentlich das Stromgünstigste, um einen Raspberry Pi zu steuern?
Hä?
Ach, du meinst, wie du, wie du, ähm...
Ach so, du meinst, wie du die, wie deine Ausgabe...
Gar nix.
PSS-H drauf.
Von deinem normalen PC.
Raspberry anschließen, PSS-H drauf.
Genau, genau wie der JSP64 schreibt.
PSS-H drauf, gut.
Wann startest du wieder mit YouTube?
Ja, vielleicht mach ich dieses Video noch...
Dieses Wochenende noch ein Video zu Battlefield 5.
Habe jetzt ja genug Gameplay aufgenommen heute.
Was sind meine PC-Specs?
Äh, das kann ich dir zeigen.
Hab ich hier irgendwo?
Ja?
Da?
Da.
Da, meine PC-Specs.
Hier.
Ist das wie...
Da muss ich...
Der Witz ist...
Ne, das ist auch so, das war so Rant jetzt.
Das hätte es früher auch nicht gegeben.
Und es ist jetzt kein Gelabern von früher, war alles besser.
Das ist Fakt, dass es das früher nicht gegeben hätte.
Guck mal, das Video habe ich gemacht vor einem Jahr.
Das ist...
Wir runden mal ein bisschen auf.
Ziemlich genau ein Jahr her.
Das heißt, ich habe mir vor einem Jahr exakt diesen Rechner gekauft.
Der war damals absolutes High-End.
Und der ist heute...
... immer noch da.
Immer noch absolutes High-End.
Es gibt nichts Schnelleres.
Ich glaube, mittlerweile gibt es...
Ich glaube, mittlerweile gibt es, ähm...
... neuere Intel-CPUs, ne?
Demnächst gibt es neue...
... Nvidia-Grafikkarten.
Aber ich habe mir eine Taus...
Also, ne?
Ich habe mir vor einem Jahr einen Rechner gekauft, der damals absolut High-End war.
Und der ist heute immer noch absolut High-End.
Früher war ein Rechner nach einem Jahr zwar nicht so, dass du es wegschmeißen konntest,
aber nach zwei Jahren konntest du ihn eigentlich vergessen.
Also, man sieht, die Entwicklung, was Hardware angeht,
hat sich schon...
Also, auch die Anforderungen der Spiele an die Hardware und an die Geschwindigkeitsverbesserung
sind schon deutlich zurückgegangen.
Im Vergleich zu, sagen wir mal, so 2005 rum oder so.
Ja, das sind meine PC-Specs.
Also, ich habe eine 69 Evo drin.
Nicht nur das.
Also, ich habe noch eine alte SSD.
Also, ich habe noch eine, ähm...
... eine 2TB vom alten Rechner-SSD.
Aber so ist es halt so, wie ich mir ihn gekauft habe, ne?
69 Evo, M.2-SSD, ein 8...
Der erste, das war...
Ich war einer der Ersten, der einen 8700K in Deutschland hatte.
Poggers, Alter!
Poggers!
Massive Poggers!
Ähm...
16 GB RAM.
RGB-RAM, weil RGB-RAM verfügbar war und alles andere nicht damals.
Eine 1080 Ti.
Ähm...
Ein ASRock mit einem 10 Gigabit-Netzwerk-Interface.
Deswegen habe ich mir das geholt.
Also, wenn man...
Bester Lüfter überhaupt.
Bester...
Ohne Scheiß.
Beste CPU-Kühler, den ich je hatte.
Sowohl vom Umfang her, was die mitliefern.
Also, man muss sagen, das Gesamtpaket von Oktur ist wirklich konkurrenzlos.
Es gibt nichts Vergleichbares.
Der Scheiß ist halt auch teuer wie Sau, ne?
Aber es ist geil.
Es ist top.
Es ist sogar noch eine zweite Klammer dabei für den zweiten Kühler hier.
Ich habe mir sogar mittlerweile Kühler-Modding-Sachen gekauft dafür, ne?
Richtig, richtig hängen geblieben.
Äh...
Ich zeige euch das mal.
Kühler-Modding.
Gibt's?
Weil man erhält das gar nicht für möglich, ne?
Ähm...
Äh...
Wo ist es denn?
Pff...
Ja, wo könnte es denn stehen?
Chromax, da ist es, genau.
Ja, Kühler-Modding.
Ich habe mir...
Ich habe mir für den Lüfter hier so Dinger geholt und...
Und so...
Heatsink-Covers.
Sowas hier.
Weil es geht.
Das bringt nichts.
Es bringt wirklich gar nichts.
Es ist auch scheiß drauf, was die auf ihrer Seite schreiben.
Vielleicht noch irgendwas verbessert.
Also es bringt nichts.
Es sieht einfach nur cool aus.
Ähm...
Ne, gut, und Netzteil, ne?
Und das beste Gehäuse finde ich, da ich hatte jetzt...
Ähm...
Also ich hatte da vorher auch das Fractal R4.
Und das Gehäuse ist wirklich gut.
Also wenn man ein gutes Gehäuse haben will, wo man auch bereit ist, ein bisschen Kohle für auszugeben.
Das ist ja nicht das billigste Gehäuse.
Das ist wirklich...
Diese...
Ich bin ein großer Fan dieser Fractal-Design-R-Dingsbums-Reihe.
Von den Gehäusen her.
Das ist wirklich toll.
Du hast auch vorne alles dabei.
Man sieht es jetzt nicht so.
Du hast vorne einen Lüfter schon dabei und einen Staubfilter.
Eine Sache, die total unterschätzt wird.
Ähm...
Staubfilter.
PC ohne Staubfilter ist nervig.
Ja.
Wann entwickelt eigentlich mal jemand einen Minimalbrowser, der so ressourcensparend wie nur möglich ist?
Gibt es ein...
Gibt es ein paar Sachen?
Das Problem ist, dass denn die Dinger halt meistens nichts können.
Und wenn...
Gibt es...
Es gibt ein paar...
Es gibt ein paar Minimal-Guys für...
Für...
Chrome.
Also für Chromium.
Oder für...
Wie heißt das jetzt?
Plink.
Plink-Engine oder so, ne?
So, ich bin schon wieder vieles zweit hinten dran mit dem Chat.
Noctua-Lüfter sind übelst hässlich.
Ja, deswegen ja auch das Noctua-Modding.
Ne.
Find ich nicht.
Ich find...
Diese ganzen Übertakter-Grafikkarten lohnen sich in der Regel nicht.
Man kann sich...
Man kann sich eine Grafikkarte...
Ich mein, die 1080 Ti, die Founders, also die, die, die...
Die Nvidia-Referenz, das Referenz-Design, kannst du ja auch schon ordentlich übertakten.
Das lohnt sich nicht.
Find ich nicht, dass sich das lohnt.
Die Dinger sind eh schon teuer genug.
Ne, den i9 hab ich nicht.
Den i9 ist blöd gewesen.
Den i9 hatte mehr Kerne und weniger Takt.
Das hat sich überhaupt nicht gelohnt für Gaming.
Oder hießen die überhaupt i9?
Was ist das eigentlich für Musik hier gerade?
Immer noch Kirby Happy.
Ich komm mit dem Chat nicht nach.
Moment.
Was hat sich der PC gekostet?
Ja, ähm...
Gute Frage.
Das Problem ist, dass die Preise nicht mehr aktuell sind, die hier stehen, ne?
Das stimmt nicht.
Das hat mehr gekostet.
Oder es ist aber so, es hätte mehr gekostet.
Im Endeffekt.
Wartet mal kurz.
Da ist die Grafikkarte ja nicht dabei.
Aber die musst du ja nicht bezahlen.
Ähm...
Ja, ich denke mal...
Guck dir...
Guck dir am besten das Video an.
Dann sag ich das irgendwo, was der Kram gekostet hat.
Guck dir...
Guck dir einfach das Video bei mir an.
Mit legendärer Kameraarbeit hier, wie man sieht.
Oben hat man eine Lüftersteuerung.
Legendäre Kameraarbeit hier.
Ist Reddit auch bei euch down?
Reddit ist öfters mal down in letzter Zeit.
Nö, Reddit ist nicht down.
Zockst du gleich noch oder was?
Ne, ich hab schon.
Ich hab schon drei...
Dreieinhalb Stunden oder so Battlefield gespielt.
Ähm...
Ich bin eigentlich fertig.
Ich wollte den Stream eigentlich schon gefühlt seit einer Stunde ausmachen.
Ja, ähm...
Ich muss jetzt langsam mal was futtern.
Ich krieg Hunger.
Also Leute, gibt's...
Gibt's noch irgendwelche Sachen, die ihr wissen wollt?
Äh...
Hier von...
Technik-Krams, den ich hier gerade losgelassen hab.
Übrigens...
Also, ich kann diese...
Muss ich...
Weil mich letztens Leute auch wieder nach Routern gefragt haben.
Ähm...
Ich kann das jedem nur empfehlen, der sich ein...
bisschen über das...
von Fritzbox, äh...
hinaus mit Routern beschäftigen will.
Und auch so ein bisschen...
in dem Bereich, wie man das...
zum Beispiel im professionellen Segment sieht.
Ähm...
Mikrotik ist jetzt nix, wo man...
vielleicht jetzt als...
als...
ähm...
Ja, so diese...
Business-Anbieter schlechthin sieht.
Ja, da hast du immer noch sowas wie Cisco.
Allerdings ist die Cisco-Preise auch absolut utopisch.
Das heißt, wenn man mal mit was rumspielen will,
was schon professionellen Ansprüchen gerecht wird.
Es gibt auch genug Provider, die Mikrotik-Zeug haben.
Ja, nicht jeder Provider kann sich für 3 Millionen...
so ein Cisco-Zeug kaufen.
Ähm...
Was trotzdem gut bedienbar ist, sowohl im SSH, als auch Web-Interface oder sonstwas.
Kann sich hier sowas kaufen. Kostet nicht viel.
Also wirklich nicht viel.
Normalerweise, wenn ich nicht sag, nicht viel, dann kostet es trotzdem 300 Euro, aber...
die Dinger kosten wirklich nicht viel. Guck mal, 50 Euro.
Für 50 Euro seid ihr auch schon ungefähr mit nem Mikrotik-Router dabei.
Könnt natürlich deutlich mehr einstellen,
als an so ner Fritzbox.
Ihr könnt PoE über den...
den Kleinen machen.
Über den hier.
Und...
Es hat sogar ein ziemlich gutes Web-Interface.
Ich zeig euch mal das Web-Interface.
Von...
den Mikrotik-Routern. So sieht das aus.
Also man sieht schon ein bisschen mehr.
Schon ein bisschen mehr, als auf so ner Fritzbox, das Ganze, ne?
Und man kann prinz... also man kann wirklich alles einstellen.
Alles machen, ne? Man kann's auf VPN und sowas einstellen.
Aber so die Mikro-Dinger zum...
Wenn man sich das einfach mal angucken will,
oder wenn man auch...
bisschen mehr machen will, also...
so ne Fritzbox hergibt, oder...
ähm...
ja, andere Ansprüche hat,
ist so'n Mikrotik-Ding das Beste, was man sich holen kann.
Alternativ macht man sich ne PF-Sense oder ne OpenSense-VM,
weil man ja wieder mehr selbst machen muss.
Aber diese Mikrotik-Dinger sind wirklich super.
Preis-Leistung ist ungeschlagen.
Machst du irgendwann mal wieder ein Hardware-Programmier-System?
Ja klar!
Äh, wir müssen das... wir müssen ja hier noch...
wir müssen das... das Meme-Tool noch fertig programmieren.
Das ist ja noch halb fertig.
Aber ich setz nicht, äh...
nicht mehr so richtig aufm Schirm gehabt.
Aber das machen wir auf jeden Fall fertig.
Also...
no joke.
Wir machen das jetzt... wir machen das wirklich fertig.
Was, ähm...
Was hattest du vor dem 8700K für einen, ähm, Prozessor, und...
würdest du an meiner Stelle, wenn ich von einem i7-2600K komme, eher zu einem...
i9-1900K oder einer kommenden Weise...
Also...
ich würde mir wahrscheinlich...
wenn ich mir jetzt nen Rechner kaufe, nen Ryzen kaufe...
also...
wenn ich den nicht hätte, den ich jetzt hätte, ne?
Dann würde ich mir wahrscheinlich irgendeinen...
also preis-leistungsmäßig... ich würd's...
wirklich machen würde ich's nicht, weil ich...
äh, hab in letzter Zeit den Hang dazu, viel zu viel Geld für den Scheiß auszugeben.
Aber preis-leistungsmäßig würd ich mir auf jeden Fall irgendein Ryzen-Ding holen.
Ob die 9900K-Dinger was bringen, weiß ich nicht, muss ich ehrlich sagen, hab ich mir auch noch nichts zu angeguckt.
Kommt drauf an, wie viel Kerne die haben und vor allem, wie die Takte... wie die Kerne getaktet sind.
Sollte das Ding...
ähm...
6 plus Kerne haben, plus quasi auch so Takten, wie das nen 8700K macht,
dann sind die mit Sicherheit fürs Gaming nicht schlecht.
Sollte der mehr Kerne haben und weniger Takt, dann kann man sich wahrscheinlich auch nen Ryzen holen.
So einfach mal aus dem Bauch raus gesagt jetzt.
ähm...
Wie gesagt, das...
das Vim-Tool machen wir fertig.
Ansonsten, wenn ihr Rechner-Zusammenstellungen sehen wollt, könnt ihr auch bei Hardware-Rad gucken, der macht das wirklich nicht schlecht.
Hat der...
hat der nicht jetzt sogar nen eigenen Shop?
Das müsst ihr uns jetzt mal angucken.
Da, ist der das?
Also, wenn ihr PC-Zusammenstellungen braucht, so.
Guckt euch das bei ihm an, der macht das wirklich nicht schlecht.
Hat der jetzt... er stimmt, der hat ja jetzt nen eigenen Shop.
Was?
Da gucken wir jetzt mal.
Gucken wir mal, was hat er denn so?
Hardware.
Also, der Shop ist schon mal nicht schlecht.
Da blickt man schon mal durch.
Okay, was ähm...
Schauen wir mal.
Was kriegt man aktuell so für den...
Preis, den ich bezahlt hab, damals für mein PC.
Der Hardware-Rad 1400, Lieferzeit 3 Werktage...
Oh, das ist aber sportlich, 3 Werktage inklusive Zusammenbau.
Da muss er sich aber...
Da muss er sich ranhalten.
Ähm...
Guck, der verbaut auch nen Ryzen.
Ja.
Das ist auch was, was ich heute, wenn ich mir nen Rechner kaufen würde, wahrscheinlich in der Preisklasse auch machen würde.
16G, ein bisschen kleinere SSD als Familie, ne Festplatte dazu.
Ähm...
So 1080 aus der 1080Ti.
Und das sieht auch rundum brauchbar aus.
Ja, und hier kriegt man das sogar noch zusammengebaut.
Dementsprechend mit Garantie auf die komplette Kiste.
Also...
Das macht gar keinen schlechten Eindruck.
Ich hoffe nur, er verdient damit ordentlich was.
Weil es wär natürlich blöd, wenn er sich jetzt quasi so...
So, so, so, so das Risiko irgendwie ans...
Anhängt, so, mit, mit dem Laden und ähm...
Quasi schon beim ersten PC dazu.
Beim ersten PC, der zurückgeschickt wird, dann drauf legt.
Das wird es, hoffe ich nicht.
Ich hoffe, der macht damit ganz gut Kohle.
Weil im Vergleich zu Kinder über YouTube ausnehmen, ist das hier doch mal ne ganz andere Kategorie.
Das ist ja...
So richtig...
Der arbeitet ja richtig dafür, hier, für die ganze Sache.
So, was gibt's denn im Hardware-Rad?
1800.
Ah, da gibt's ne 1080Ti und...
Das ist im Prinzip so das, was ich hab.
Von, von der, von...
Dem...
Maßstab her, ja.
Oh ja, das Verlöten ist wichtig.
Ich, ich hab ja mein 8700K geköpft, ne.
Boah, hab ich geschwitzt.
Ich hab's euch ja schon mal erzählt.
Ich hab das sogar, ich hab sogar das Video dazu aufgenommen.
Aber ich werd das nicht veröffentlichen.
Das ist zu langweilig, irgendwie mir ne halbe Stunde beim CPU, ähm, Kleber abkratzen zuzugucken.
Ja.
Ich sagte, ich hab an den 8700 geköpft.
Guck mal, ob's Bilder davon gibt.
Da hab ich geschwitzt, ey.
Ich sag's euch.
Ja.
Das gab's leider nicht mehr.
Das Deli-Tool von der Bauer.
Ja, so sieht das dann aus.
Leute, und glaubt mir.
Man schwitzt.
Man muss die CPU aufmachen, da holt man sich so nen...
So nen Tool, so ein ähnliches Tool wie das hier für.
Da kann man die CPU reinschrauben.
Und dreht das dann.
Und, und macht dann quasi hier oben diese...
Also ich mein, das was ihr hier seht, ist das was unter diesem...
Silbernen...
Was hier oben, unter diesem Heatspreader.
Was da drunter ist.
Und dann setzt man das da rein und dreht das Ganze.
Und dann macht's dann halt irgendwann Klack und es geht ab.
Und dann sieht das drunter so aus.
Bloß das halt hier, wie man hier sieht, so ne ganz fette, weiß ich nicht, so ne Silikon-Kleber-Mischung drauf ist.
Und die muss man halt abkratzen.
Und ich sag euch Leute...
Das hier sieht übrigens nicht gut aus unten.
Ich sag euch Leute, wenn ihr erstmal anfangt...
Ich glaub das Teil hatte ich.
Ja, Dr. Delete, das Ding hatte ich.
Und ich sag euch, wenn ihr erstmal anfangt auf eurer CPU...
Auf eurem CPU-Träger-Material.
Ja, da sieht... So sieht's aus, genau.
So sieht's aus.
Scheiß-Auflösung, aber ja.
So sieht's im Prinzip aus, ja.
Silikon-Paste.
Drumherum.
Genauso sah das aus.
Und die muss man abkratzen.
Ich sag euch, da geht euch der Arsch.
Wenn ihr da mit der Kreditkarte drauf rumkratzt.
Alkohol nehmen, Kreditkarte und das abkratzen.
Dann seid ihr eine halbe Stunde, Stunde beschäftigt.
Und ihr seid permanent kurz davor im Kopf, dass ihr gerade eure CPU schrottet.
Und zu dem Zeitpunkt gab's halt diese CPU nicht mehr.
Hätte ich den 8700K geschrottet, hätte ich quasi ein halbes Jahr erstmal auf eine CPU warten müssen.
Weil die Dinger waren ja nicht lieferbar.
Ich hab geschwitzt, ey. Ich hab echt geschwitzt.
Ja, und dann hab ich drauf, ähm...
Flüssig... Flüssigmetall drauf gemacht.
Und zwar den, äh, äh...
Thermal Grizzly Conductor Note.
Thermal Grizzly Conductor Note hab ich drauf gemacht.
Genau. Den da.
Flüssigmetall.
Ja, sieht man's ja auch.
Ne, nicht da. Nicht da. Das ist doch Blödsinn.
Oder... Oder war's das hier?
Ne, das war die normale Wärmeleitpaste, ne?
Ne, das macht man nicht hier drauf, das macht man unten drunter.
Weil die meisten, ähm...
Kühlkörper das auch gar nicht so gut vertragen.
Diese Metallmischung hier.
Ja, und das macht man dann hier unten drunter auf die CPU drauf.
Und...
Die ganz Hardcore-Leute machen dann...
Den...
Kühler direkt hier drauf.
Aber ich hab den...
Den Deckel wieder drauf gemacht.
Hier. Den Heat Spreader.
Den da. Wieder oben drauf.
Da drauf dann, ähm, nochmal Wärmeleitpaste.
Und dann ist das Ding halt einfach...
Gleich mal...
Gefühlt 20 Grad kühler.
Und ich kann ihn bis auf 5,1 Gigahertz takten.
Ordentlich.
5,1 ist ordentlich für einen 8700.
Multi-Core Enhancement.
Also sprich, es laufen auch alle Kerne auf diesem Takt.
Und das mit dem Noctua-Lüfter.
Das ist wirklich toll. Da hab ich Glück gehabt mit der CPU.
Ja.
Warum hast du das gemacht?
Ist die CPU zu heiß geworden?
Ja, einmal weil ich gucken wollte,
wie weit man sie übertacken kann.
Und sie ist auch ziemlich warm geworden.
Es ist DEFINITIV keine Pflicht.
Ja, muss man dazu sagen.
Wenn man 6700K kauft
und zufrieden ist
mit dem, was
er standardmäßig kann
und zufrieden ist mit, wie weit man ihn
quasi bis an die Temperaturgrenze
übertacken kann.
Man muss ihn nicht...
Man muss das nicht machen.
Das ist wirklich nicht notwendig,
dafür, dass es gut funktioniert.
Wenn man gucken will, wie weit man ihn maximal...
Ich hab sogar nen Stream. Da müsste glaube ich beim Sibaro
sogar im Streamer-Chief drin sein.
Ähm, wo ich das Ding übertaktet hab.
Oder beziehungsweise versucht hab,
wie weit es geht.
So, und ich wollte einfach gucken, wie weit
ich übertacken kann das Ganze.
Und da war halt einfach zu schnell
temperaturmäßig Schluss.
Man muss ja auch dazu sagen,
wenn man jetzt quasi bis ans Temperaturlimit geht
und die CPU bei Prime oder bei
irgendwelchen Tests Fehler wirft
nach dem Übertacken, kann das durchaus sein,
dass die CPU eben keine Fehler mehr hat,
wenn sie kühler bleibt.
Also Übertaktungspotential und
Kühlung geht da schon Hand in Hand.
Was man ja auch daran sieht, dass die ganzen
Weltrekord-Übertakter
da irgendwie mit flüssigem...
Was ist das? Wasserstoff?
Ne, keine Ahnung.
Mit so Flüssigkühlung.
Kram.
Eis.
Übertakten.
Stickstoff ist es glaube ich, oder? Stickstoff?
Keine Ahnung.
Ich weiß nicht.
Ja, Stickstoff, genau.
Komm, ein Stickstoff war es.
Das ist witzig. Wir haben uns das auf der Gamescom
vor ein paar Jahren mal angeguckt mit so zwei
Weltrekord-Übertakter.
Haben uns das mal gezeigt.
Es ist...
Es ist schon abgedreht.
Die müssen ja...
Ich hoffe, man sieht das in irgendeinem Video.
Das war ohne Sound. Wir wollen das mal kurz was zeigen.
Da ist er ja.
Der Bauer.
Wo zeigen sie das denn?
Weil man muss...
Das ist Kacke.
Sieht das nicht richtig.
Egal. Man muss dann die Dinger
teilweise mit dem Bunsenbrenner wieder warm machen.
Also sprich, man schüttet das rein,
man übertaktet das und wenn es nicht funktioniert,
muss man die erstmal mit dem Bunsenbrenner irgendwie wieder warm machen
und dann wieder Neues rein.
Das ist total abgedreht.
Und letztendlich hat man ja nichts davon.
Es ist ja nicht so, dass man den PC laufen lassen würde
mit den Settings. Es geht ja bloß darum,
mal irgendwie einen 3D-Marker
oder so laufen zu lassen, in der Hoffnung,
dass man nicht abkackt.
Und dann zu sagen, hey, ich hab den längsten
beim Übertakten.
Also man muss sagen, das Köpfen von der CPU,
das hat mehr als 10 Grad gebracht.
Ich würde mal sagen, fast 20 Grad
haben die so bei mir gebracht.
Riesenunterschied.
Der Takt ist jetzt nicht voll hoch.
Guck mal.
53 Grad.
Nix im Endeffekt.
Also der bleibt wirklich ordentlich kühl.
Das Windows sieht aber komisch aus.
Warum?
Das sieht aus wie jedes Windows.
Bei Windows kann man ja nix einstellen.
Windows sieht überall nach Windows aus.
Leider.
Tja.
Das fragen sich alle,
warum Intel
die paar Cent bei der Wärmeleitpaste
gespart hat.
Ich meine, Intel
hätte ja einfach
gar keine Wärmeleitpaste machen können,
sondern
den Heatspreader an die CPU löten.
Also,
das ist ja nicht zum Aufmachen gedacht.
Die Wärmeleitpaste hast du ja quasi,
weil
die CPU ein Teil ist
und der Kühlkörper ein anderer Teil.
Das heißt, da machst du Wärmeleitpaste
dazwischen, dass die Dinger besonders gute
Leitungen dazwischen haben. Allerdings,
nachdem die CPU und der Heatspreader
vor der CPU
nicht zwei einzelne Teile sind,
in dem Sinn, dass der End-User
die abmachen soll, könnte man die einfach
verlöten. So wie das übrigens AMD macht
und Intel früher auch gemacht hat.
Und bei den neuen CPUs, glaube ich,
auch wieder macht.
Und dann bräuchte man den ganzen Scheiß gar nicht.
Im Prinzip ist das ein Witz.
Ja, das ist quasi das
High-End-Enthusiasten-Modell,
wie man da so schön sagt,
gewesen von Intel.
Was eigentlich unsinnig
teuer war. Nicht nur die CPU,
sondern auch die Mainboards.
Und dann so einen Kack mit Wärmeleitpaste
zu machen. Ich meine, man muss sich mal überlegen,
der 8700K ist quasi so
der,
das obere Ende der Intel-CPUs
für was quasi so im Desktop-Gaming-Bereich
drinne war.
Oder immer noch drinne ist.
Auch im
Hinblick auf
Übertakten.
Aber vielleicht wollten sie gar nicht, dass die Leute so weit
arbeiten können, weil die Leute sich
quasi die nächsten Krams erst mal 3 Jahre
nicht mehr kaufen müssen.
Bei der heutigen Entwicklung,
da muss ich mal überlegen, ich habe es ja gerade gesagt,
der Rechner ist
ein Jahr alt, ziemlich genau
jetzt, ein Jahr alt.
War damals High-End, ist heute
immer noch genauso High-End
und wird mit einem
8700K und
einer 1080T in einem Jahr
auf einmal unnütz sein.
Also das ist ein Rechner, wo man theoretisch
5 Jahre
ganz gut mitspielen
kann. Das ist halt
ein Witz, wenn man sich überlegt, dass
du früher nach 2 Jahren noch einen Rechner kaufen musstest.
Aber wenn man vielleicht
dann nach 3 Jahren nicht mal das alles in
Ultra spielen möchte, kann man mit diesem Rechner
ohne Probleme 5 Jahre auskommen.
Aber wirklich ohne Probleme
sollte die Entwicklung so weitergehen, wie sie
aktuell ist. Aber ich werde damit
keine 5 Jahre auskommen. Ich behalte den jetzt noch
ein Jahr und dann mal gucken,
was
dann angesagt ist.
Und vielleicht hole ich mir dann in einem Jahr,
wenn AMD da richtig was
vorlegt, ich hoffe ja AMD legt auch mal im
Grafikkartenbereich richtig was vor,
vielleicht hole ich mir dann mal wieder ein komplettes
AMD System oder zumindest ein System mit
AMD CPU.
Max, ich habe mal eine Frage.
Ist es okay, wenn ich
Exposed Host anhabe auf der PS4
und die Pods freigegeben habe,
also beides funktioniert
das?
Also Exposed Host plus
Port Weiterleiten schließt sich aus.
Weil Exposed Host
in der Regel besagt,
das ist ein bisschen unterschiedlich je nach Hersteller, aber in der Regel,
dass du alle Ports
auf diesen einen Host weiterleitest.
Das heißt, wenn du Port Weiterleitung
plus Exposed Host machst,
hast du schon alle Port Weiterleitungen,
also du brauchst die Port Weiterleitung nicht mehr.
Die sind schon dabei.
Wobei ich generell nie
Exposed Host machen würde.
Und wie das aussieht mit UPnP anlassen oder deaktivieren,
ich habe UPnP immer aus.
Man kann das einschalten,
aber wenn man nicht selbst konfigurieren möchte, großartig.
Max, glaubst du, dass Quantencomputer
in Zukunft dazu fähig sein werden,
aktuelle Kryptographie
weitestgehend außer Kraft zu setzen?
Nein, werden sie nicht.
Zumindest nicht aktuelle Kryptographie
im Ganzen.
Weil
die Sachen, die du knacken willst,
müssen sich ja erstmal
gut eignen
für das, was so ein Quantencomputer kann.
Aber da bin ich kein
Experte irgendwie drin.
Das heißt, wenn du Sachen hast,
die sich vom Ansatz her
nicht gut eignen mit einem Quantencomputer
zu machen, dann kannst du das auch nicht
einfach mit einem Quantencomputer knacken.
Und das ist ein komplett neues Feld,
also ich gehe nicht davon aus,
dass unsere aktuelle Kryptographie
komplett useless ist damit.
Ich habe keine Ahnung davon so richtig.
Ich habe leider nichts großartiges zu erzählen
im Detail.
Ich weiß nicht, ob Hash-Errechnen gut funktioniert,
ehrlich gesagt.
Was geht jetzt mit der Musik ab?
Also Primzahlen zerlegen und sowas
funktioniert halt super.
Aber ob Hash, beziehungsweise
ob Hashen gut geht?
Hashen ist ja so eine, also
wenn du Hash in Anführungsstrichen knacken willst,
das ist ja so eine
Brutforce, wir probieren alles durch
Geschichte. Ich weiß nicht, wie sich dies
in der Form dafür eignet, keine Ahnung.
Man
man errechnet
Hash in dem Sinn ja.
Also man rechnet Hash in dem Sinn ja nicht
zurück. Man berechnet
einmalig einen Hash aus irgendeinem Klartext
und diesen
Hash, den du dann hast, kannst du ja nicht mehr zurückrechnen.
Also wenn, das kam,
also ich weiß, es wird oft gesagt, so nach dem Motto
ja, dann wird quasi, der Hash
wird errechnet oder irgendwie
oder zurückgerechnet, das stimmt ja gar nicht.
Es wird einfach ganz viel Input durchprobiert,
ob der gleiche Hash wieder rauskommt.
Das ist ja alles. Deswegen dauert das ja auch so
lange.
Sollte man den Hash zurückrechnen können,
was bei einem Hash an sich gar nicht geht,
weil du ja quasi
Informationen wegwirfst,
also wenn du was verschlüsselst,
also wenn du was symmetrisch
verschlüsselst, das heißt, du hast
einen Klartext, den
verschlüsselst du mit einem Schlüssel und dann kriegst du
einen verschlüsselnden Text raus,
dann hast du ja die gleichen Informationen
in dem verschlüsselnden Text drin, halt nur
verschlüsselnd. Da fällt halt nichts weg.
Bei einem Hash ist es umgedreht.
Wenn du deinen Klartext hashst,
werden Teile
weggeworfen. Die sind nicht in diesem Hash drin.
Dementsprechend kannst
du auch von den Hash nicht mehr
zurückrechnen auf die, auf
den ursprünglichen Wert
und dementsprechend gibt es auch bei
jedem Hash-Algorithmus immer,
muss es geben logischerweise,
unterschiedliche
Ausgangstexte,
die den gleichen Hash ergeben.
Und theoretisch natürlich sogar unendlich
viele, wobei die Chance, einen zu finden,
ziemlich klein ist.
Es gibt eine unendlich große Anzahl an
Klartext, ja, und
der, den
verkürzt du ja immer auf den
Hash, ja, den zerschneidest du ja immer quasi
in Teile, baust da draußen dann deinen Hash
zusammen. Das heißt, es gibt theoretisch
unendlich viele Hash-Kollisionen, aber
ähm, die sind halt sehr schwierig zu
finden.
Und deswegen kannst du der Hash
halt nicht zurückrechnen.
Linux.de würdest du empfehlen für
ein Dual-Monitor-Setup?
I3. I3 ist der beste,
die beste, Desktop kann man dazu
gar nicht sagen,
die beste grafische Oberfläche
finde ich für ein,
für Linux. I3, beste, ja.
Soll ich dir das mal zeigen?
Rastler I3.
Wir können unsere, ich kann hier mal
meine, meine Feuerbahn machen. Willst du mal I3 sehen?
Falls du es nicht kennst.
I3.
Gibt's in den Stream, gibt's auch immer
ein Archiv, wo wir das eingerichten,
eingerichtet haben. Ja, I3 Gaps, das ist auch
ein I3 Gaps, den ich hier hab.
Nein, das ist mein Audio Interface,
beziehungsweise da, wo ich den Kopf,
da will ich nicht connecten.
Ja, also das hier
ist I3. Du hast halt
bei I3, du hast halt im Prinzip
nur Vollbild, ne? Du hast hier oben
verschiedene Desktops, die kannst du durchschalten.
Also jetzt, im 1er
hab ich immer einen Browser, auf dem 2er hab ich mal ein Terminal,
auf dem 3er kannst du dann was auch
immer noch aufmachen, ja, was du so willst. Du kannst
dir im Prinzip bis zu 10
Desktops da hinlegen.
Ähm...
Ja, von den Gaps hat man...
Ich mag die Gaps. Ich finde da ist...
Das grenzt
die Fenster besser voneinander ab.
Ich hab auch, deswegen hab ich auch nur 2 Pixel Gaps oder so.
So diese Setups
mit...
Diese Setups mit irgendwie
60 Pixel Gaps, wo du dann da ein Fenster hast
und so, das finde ich auch übelst Platzverschwendung.
Ich mag die Gaps einfach, weil du ein bisschen
weil du ein bisschen klarer den Unterschied zwischen den
Fenstern siehst. Ich finde das
sieht optisch einfach irgendwie
angenehmer aus.
Und auch hier außen drum herum, ein bisschen
die Gaps, finde ich persönlich
hübscher. Ich bin aber auch eher ein Fan von kleinen Gaps.
Ja, und du hast
dann alles Fullscreen, das heißt, ähm...
Es heißt nicht, dass man nicht Fenster
machen kann, ja, man kann auch Fenster machen, wenn man
will, aber in der Regel will man nicht.
Äh, E3 ist halt Tiling, also sprich
du hast alles Fullscreen, machst du ein 2. Fenster
auf, ist es gesplittet, machst du ein 3. Fenster
auf, ist nochmal gesplittet, du kannst die Dinger verschieben,
per Tastatur, oder auch
hier in der Höhe und so, äh,
oder auch Fullscreen machen.
Es ist halt eine recht
Tastatur-orientierte
Sache, ja.
Muss man sagen. Also wenn man, wenn man
gerne klickt und wenn man, also für
Desktop, wenn man gerne klickt und wenn man
überhaupt einen Desktop haben möchte, das ist ja gar kein
Desktop, gibt's ja hier gar nichts drauf.
Oder wenn man
gerne Fenster, Fenstermanagement
mit Maus macht, Fenster, überhaupt
Fenster hat, ja, Fenster rumschiebt, Fenster...
Minimiert, sonst was,
dann ist E3 nix.
Aber ich muss sagen, ich benutze E3
auf allen meinen Linux-Systemen privat,
seit Jahren, und ich verwende das auch
seit Jahren auf der Arbeit, das hat sich bewährt.
Und ich finde, das ist
der beste, einfachste und
schnellste Desktop, den es für Linux gibt.
Leider nur für
X11, äh, für X.Org.
Für Wayland gibt's was,
aber Wayland an sich hat da auch so seine Probleme.
Nutzt du keinen Composite-Manager?
Doch, doch hab ich, ich hab, ähm,
Compton hab ich an.
Aber der macht nicht viel.
Ich hatte den mal eingestellt, dass
die, dass das
inaktive Fenster ein bisschen gedimmt ist und
sowas, aber das ging mir nachher Zeit auf den Keks.
Aktuell hab ich eigentlich nur Compton, weil
die, weil das dann in der
VM besser läuft, dank
ein bisschen OpenGL und
ich glaub, dass das switchen war
schneller in der VM.
Aber ansonsten benutze ich
da nicht viel von. Mach mal
Übergangs-Effekte, ich mag das nicht. Ne, ne, ich, das
hab, ich hab das schon alles ausprobiert, ich mag keine Übergangs-Effekte.
Ich will auf den Knopf drücken und es muss
da sein. Ich mag das nicht. Ich, ich,
ich hab auch, ich, ich hab auch nirgendswo
anders großartige, ähm,
großartige Effekte an.
Ich will Knopf drücken
und es ist da. Knopf drücken und es ist da.
So muss das sein.
Snappy, genau. Ja.
I3. Also, mehr, im, im,
vielmehr ist es ja das Witzige bei I3. Vielmehr
kann man dazu gar nicht sagen.
So ist halt I3. Ah, da macht man sich
auch eine schöne Bar hier oben, dass man wichtig
Sachen drauf sieht. Oh ja, der IP liegt wieder.
Mein Gott, ähm.
Das ist ne Arch-Linux.
Also, Manjaro kann ich auch nur
empfehlen für Desktop-Betrieb, vor allem auch für den
VM-Betrieb.
Hast du zu Hause
ein P-Hole, also quasi Adblocker per DNS?
Hatte ich mal.
Hat aber leider mehr Probleme gemacht,
als er genutzt hat.
Und deswegen hab ich jetzt wieder
ganz normal, ja,
uBlock Origin
im Browser. Ja.
Den da.
Der tut's auch.
DDoS ist raus, ja.
Nice.
I hacked localhost.
So Leute, ich mach jetzt Schluss.
Ähm, und geh was futtern.
Ich bin da schon wieder.
4 Stunden 39.
Ist geil. Ich hab jetzt eineinhalb Stunden gelabert.
Einfach nur. Eine Stunde 40 Minuten.
Wir sind quasi, seit kurz nach drei Stunden
sind wir quasi fertig mit Battlefield gewesen.
Wir haben noch eine Stunde, eineinhalb Stunden geschwätzt.
Ja.
Ich hoffe, euch hat's gefallen.
Mal gucken, ob ich irgendwie auf die Reihe
krieg, ein Video mal aufzunehmen zu Battlefield 5.
Weil ich mein, genug Videomaterial hab ich jetzt.
Zwar ohne Sound, weil sonst haben wir Power Metal
im Hintergrund auf YouTube und ich krieg Instant Strike.
Aber ich kann ja mal
meine 5 Cent zu dem Game ablassen.
Und dass ich's immer noch kacke finde.
Leider.
Aber ich hätte mal so Bock auf ein ordentliches Battlefield wieder.
Könnt ihr euch gar nicht vorstellen, ey.
Wie viel Bock ich mal wieder auf ein ordentliches
Battlefield hätte.
Vielleicht wird ja Bad Company 3 gut.
Falls es überhaupt Bad Company 3 wird.
Ich hätte so Bock auf wieder ein geiles Battlefield.
Nichts auf so einem gräulichen
Animations-Crap da.
Wie Battlefield 5.
Boah.
Ich kann ja, ich darf nicht an die Animationen denken.
Krieg ich Anfälle.
Okay, Leute.
Macht's gut.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Bis denn. Tschüss.